I want you to look at something right
now thank you some major goal you want
or maybe it's one you're already working
on and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little fire a little
encouragement to get back in the game
again here's what I want you to look at
they're winners and they're losers and
there are people who have not discovered
how to win and all they need is some
coaching all they need is some insight
or different strategy of plan of action
to make some adjustments that will open
up the key to a whole new future for
them that will give them access to the
unlimited power that they have within
themselves that's all that they need so
what I want you to do is think about
something you want for you that's real
for you and I don't even want you to say
I can do that I don't want you to assume
that see five years ago when I started
out in this area I would not have been
able to make the mental leap that I
would be up to where I am right now
to be able to say something to yourself
that will enable you to maintain a level
of Integrity with yourself that when you
say this even when you face tremendous
setbacks it will be a benchmark to keep
you in the game to keep you moving
forward and experimenting and
readjusting your strategy and your plan
of action continuously looking for ways
to win so what is that something
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because of my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit in my business partner and the
thing that kept me going was studying
the stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to get
rich with Les Brown enjoy
when you got an idea you want to move on
you might not have the money you might
not have the education you might not
have the support of the resources you
need what is that something
that can keep us going that will enable
us to act on our grief what's one of
those keys
that will begin to help us to discover
the secrets to our Dream here's what I
want you to repeat after me please with
power and conviction say it's possible
that's all I want you to do when you
look at your dream you say to yourself
every day it's possible
you say that every day to yourself it's
possible because what does that do see
it begins to change your belief system
see the way in which we operate ladies
and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us whatever you've
done up to this point all that it really
is is a duplication it's a reproduction
of what you believe subconsciously that
you deserve and what's possible for your
life
most people operate out of their
personal history out of their memory
things they've done things have
experienced things they've seen things
that they have observed what I'm
suggesting that you operate out of a
larger vision of yourself I want you to
see yourself doing what you want to do
experiencing what you want to experience
it having what you want to have doing
what it is that gives your life the
meaning and value operate out of your
imagination not your memory because
whenever you look at where you want to
go I wanted to warn you you will have
some conversation back here after you go
through the data that you've experienced
in life saying you can't do it
and so what you want to begin to do is
ignore that inner conversation
well most people ladies and gentlemen
when something happens to them what they
do is they begin to believe that that's
the way it is that's the way it's always
been and they can't see the possibility
of it being any different
example
before in April 1954
the common belief the universal belief
because it had been tried again and
again and again and people have failed
the belief was that man was not
physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier that
he could not run a mile in less than
four minutes that was the belief on the
planet it had never been done
but here's what happened ladies and
gentlemen
Roger Bannister came along
and he broke the four-minute barrier
now here's What's significant about that
since that time up to this day over 20
000 people have done it including high
school kids
what changed
20 000 people what changed here's what
happened when they got on the track they
knew it had been done
and because they knew it had been done
there was a new belief about this
barrier about this goal that was
unreachable
and those 20 000 people got in a race
believing
knowing in their heart that someone had
done it that it's possible that they
could do it
and I'm saying that if you know anybody
that had some goals Some Dream something
they wanted to do
and they did it the knives saying that
you know in your heart that if someone
has done it then you can do it it's
possible
and that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's it's possible
that you can make your dream become
reality
and so as you begin to look at where you
want to go
beginning to embrace that
it's possible I'm blessed and highly
favored I've got a lot going for me I've
got some good stuff in me
and it's possible that I can bring my
greatness out here in the universe
that I can do what I want to do it's
possible I can write my own book I can
have my own business I I can take the
trip and travel around the world it's
possible I can bounce back from
adversity and reinvent my life it's
possible regardless of where I am the
things can get better for me it's
possible I'm thinking about two men
right here in Chicago who are fairly
successful
similar background
educated they work for a corporation for
many years
and they were among many people that
were laid off two guys who were very
good friends
one went out looking for a job for
several weeks along with the other one
and they face disappointment and
rejection again and again and again they
couldn't find any work
which is the story of many people across
this country
one guy stopped
he became discouraged
he stopped going
he stayed home looking at television
became very argumentative and toxic with
his wife
drinking beer getting on the phone
talking to his other negative unemployed
friends
and he just gave up
the other guy kept looking for a job
everywhere he could go every time he
could get an opportunity kept asking
people networking checking the
newspapers every day kept going
everywhere he could trying to find a job
you have too much education you're
overqualified you won't be here long
enough he kept going he kept going
he went to a place and said look here I
tell you what if you can't hire me and I
know you can use my talents abilities
and skills I don't want to sit home and
do nothing just just let me do some
volunteer work you don't have to give me
anything all right I just want to work I
want to be busy
God said okay it's on you now but don't
don't expect me to give you anything
it's okay this guy came in and worked he
was the first one there the last one to
leave was the best employee there
about four weeks later
one of the top managers quit
they were looking for a replacement
guess who they selected
this other guy this guy who was
volunteering his time
he got the job
what was the difference between the two
men
eyesight and mine sight eyesight is
judging on what you see
judging according to appearances
but mindsight is how you interpret what
you see one guy said it's not possible
it's over I'm finished I can't do it I
can't make it
he surrendered I've faced rejection
again and again I'm not going anymore
there are no jobs out there
but this other guy
he felt that in spite of the nose and
rejections in spite of how bad the
economy is in spite of what the
newspapers are saying
that it's possible
that somebody somewhere
will give me a job he just kept going
thinking it was possible
and guess what ladies and gentlemen
that's what we have to do with our
dreams
because things happen to you in life
that you can never ever anticipate and
many times when those things happen you
want to give up
I remember when I was in broadcasting
when I was a disc jockey I became very
controversial not only being a disc
jockey but I felt that radio was
something that you not only entertain
people with but you also Empower them
you educate them
and I got fired I didn't just leave they
fired me
that was a shock
good
I said wait a minute
they took my microphone I thought that
was who I was
no no ladies and gentlemen it wasn't
I had to do something else
and I didn't know what else I could do
see here's what I'm looking at what are
the uses for your life right now that
you haven't even reached for yet see I
believe that when you don't have enough
encouragement to act on your dreams or
ideas or you're not enlightened enough
that life will act on you
see life had moved on me and said Les
Brown you have outgrown this it's time
for you to do something else well I
wasn't enlightened enough I organized
some disc joggers and got my job back
so they had to find me a gift
find twice
here's what I did I had to think of
something else
and so a guy suggested to me he said Les
why don't you run for office
I said
I've never known anything about
how to operate in the political Arena
I've encouraged people to register to
vote and get out to vote but I don't
know anything about politics he said
neither do the people who run for office
all the time
so Iran now here's what I'm suggesting
Iran you got to do what you can where
you are with what you have
I didn't have any money
I didn't know anything about the
political process
I didn't even have any support
but here's what the guy told me it's
possible you could win
that's all I had
I was running against an endorsed
candidate
he was an incumbent he had the newspaper
support all of the leadership in the
community
and I was challenging this guy
so I had a saying when I was on radio
stand up for what you believe in because
you can fall for anything
and I would go door-to-door I have my
kids on one side of the street I would
be on the other and I'd I'd knock on
doors hello my name is Les Brown tell
everybody I'm still standing hey get on
the phone shout Less Problems to my
house today you know the ball on the
radio with the big mouth yeah
say he's still standing
see I'm saying just just keep moving
don't start feeling sorry for yourself
don't spend time blaming and talking
about what happened to you see whatever
you talk about that's what you multiply
and expand in your life experience so
don't talk about stuff unless you wanted
to keep on happening to you all right
so
I got in that kind of option
as I continue to do that
have my children with me we're going
door to door didn't have enough money
eventually we got close to the election
and something happened that really
surprised me guys who I thought were
going to even support me I'll stay out
of it various powerful Community leaders
they became involved in it and they
endorsed my opponent
I felt devastated now that's going to
happen to you when you're working on
your dream things are going to happen
that's going to catch you on the Blind
Side that was shocking to me they didn't
have to do that all they had to do just
stay out of it
but here they go come up and they're
messing with me
now that's going to happen you've got
some people who believe it's their
personal business to stop you from
living your dream all right
but I didn't deal with that you want to
make your dream come true you got to
stay focused some people rather get even
than get ahead stay focused on where you
want to go
I just kept on doing what I was supposed
to do
and so I was driving to the radio
station my opponent had over twenty
thousand dollars I had less than eight
hundred dollars
as I was in the radio station the guy
said you're going to make a commercial I
said yes he said it better be a good one
because that money can't go pretty far
here
and I sat there in the middle control
room and I was thinking
and here's what happens when you get
still
stuff will start coming something said
call your mama you used to talk about
your mother on the air all the time ask
her to say a few words for you that'll
be a different kind of political Spa
so I called my mama
and I had a a gospel record playing in
the background
battle
s
and then I had my mother say hello this
is Mrs Mamie Brown when I raised my sons
I raised him to be good children when
they got out of hand I'd beat their
behind and made them go right please
vote for my son he's a good boy
usually in the state representative race
maybe three or four thousand people will
come out to vote in a primary and that
primary race over 27 000 people came out
and voted said I'm voting for Les Brown
because his mama said he's a good boy
laughs
I won ladies and gentlemen I won
so you've got to be willing to stay
focused to be creative to be relentless
because things are going to happen to
you when you're working on your dream
when you get on track I remember when I
first got involved in speaking one of
the main things that speakers like to do
is fake to speak to a certain
Association that they have over ten
thousand of their sales reps that come
to this convention and I was relentless
I kept saying it's possible it's
possible see what I want to let you know
and set you up for because you said it's
possible don't mean that you're not
gonna have any problems
that Murphy's Law ain't gonna come and
slap you side the head
oh you say it's possible okay it's
possible
well I was working I kept saying it's
possible they got other speakers on this
program I can be on that program too I
kept selling myself I got all fired up
and I was calling him every day every
day and the lady finally said Mr Brown I
tell you what we want you to come in and
talk to our sales Executives you got to
kind of fire and guts that they want
that will motivate them and let me tell
you something else we want you to bring
your motivational tapes you're going to
need at least fifty thousand dollars
worth of tapes I said is that right yes
because they want to keep that drive
alive I said all right I call a guy to
duplicate my tapes I said Don how you
doing this is less let me tell you I got
a major speaking engagement I said man
it's a speaker's dream I need over 50
000 worth of product he said Les you
don't have that kind of credit laughs
I said I know but Don I can sell that
just just right after speaking
engagement I'll give you money in four
days he said are you sure less I said
yes but I got a major speaking
engagement and they told me to do it he
said man that's a big order let me talk
with the lady with you I said hold on
just a minute man call the lady back
hello Evelyn how are you
hi it's bro I got Don on the phone what
did you
did just an engagement yes you do and
what else you suggest less uh people
they buy a lot of tapes your takes a
very popular among them I'm saying bring
at least fifty thousand dollars worth of
tapes less you'll sell everything you
got and more I said did you hear that
dog he said yes I said now if anybody
else has to make a decision are you the
final person she said I'm the final
person I will send you the contract I
want you I said you'll hear that Don he
said yes I said oh yeah of little faith
I said duplicate the text man hunk the
photo
well
he duplicate the tapes
one week came by
I'm checking the mail every day
no contract
I said come on Murphy don't start
nothing man come on
and give me a break come on you know
to say fair come on
come on everybody come on I talked to
myself you know
I don't want to call him right now
two weeks passed by Murphy said don't
you think you ought to call who
I said okay I call I say hello
this is Les Brown calling how are you
doing unless I said fine I said I'm
Evelyn hasn't sent my contract out yet
any additional information you need so
unless you haven't heard I said no I
said Evelyn died
I said
did she say anything about me
when I got home
I was so wiped out
and Murphy was in the house waiting on
me
then
is it possible you want to listen to
some of your tapes
but ladies and gentlemen here's what I
had to do
I had to begin to focus on what was the
solution that this was not the only
place that I'll be able to sell those
products
and as I begin to challenge myself and
got to help and support and some other
input I eventually did a trip longer but
it was challenging if I was riding with
a friend the other day and I I know this
friend of mine who has been working on a
job where she's been miserable for a
long time she was telling me about how
she was miserable on the job and how how
she was so unhappy so I said
full and if it's causing you that much
pain I say why don't you just quit and
do something else and she said something
that really put her in the chorus line
with a lot of other people she said I
would but
and then I started thinking about that I
said let me take a poll so I started
talking to other people and I would ask
them what they were doing and I said but
is that your passion and they would say
no I said then what's your real passion
and they would tell me what their real
passion was then I said well then why
aren't you doing what you really want to
do oh I can do it but
and they would continue on so this word
you know but just kept on coming up and
then it also has some friends like water
and Coulda and shooter
and one day I'm gonna have my own
business those people who talk about one
day I'm gonna some of y'all know some of
those one day I'm going to people raise
your hand
some of you get up in the morning look
in the mirror at that person
I just tease and I just tease all right
so how is it that many times
we block ourselves and we use these
words almost like we're in a trance
like with sleepwalking through life that
we find ways to cancel out our dreams
that I think that but is a dream killer
that a lot of things that we want to do
a lot of places we would like to go a
lot of things we would like to
experience and we just stop at but and
we Bill a case in fact I was reading
something the other day that that talked
about but it says but is an argument for
our limitations and when we argue for
our limitations we get to keep them
see but will cause you to procrastinate
but will cause you to hide out behind
fear but will cause you to come up with
all type of excuses that you can
validate your inaction and not acting on
your dream and right now more than ever
people need to look for ways to live
their dream people need to look for ways
to make it on their own there is no such
thing as job security there's no such
thing as a storm proof or tragic proof
life there are no guarantees today
ladies and gentlemen the illusion is
gone there was a time when when we
graduated from high school you're told
go to college and get out and you go and
work for a corporation for 30 or 40
years they'll give your goal watching
you'll retire
a special announcement that day is gone
that day is gone never to return again
so instead of P
ihype living in
feeling stressed out feeling powerless
feeling like victims I think it should
be a time that we need to begin to look
at ways that we can become an active
force in our own lives look at ways when
we can decide to take charge of our own
destiny look at ways when we can decide
to design a life of substance and begin
to truly live our dreams and it's time
for people to decide I'm ready to get on
with my life Shake somebody's hand on
you right enough a guy named Bob may say
to say don't let nobody turn you around
do that right quick
now you know a lot of people say I'm
going to live my life one day when
things get right
when I get all my bills paid
when I get my feet on the ground I say
what have you been walking on
see they're no problem free moments god
named dimples had a record one time
called if it ain't one thing it's
another
and I say if it ain't one thing is 12
others
Always Something There
to build a case on why you can't move on
why you can't grow to the next level why
you can't begin to manifest your
greatness why you can't begin to live
life on your terms Always Something
There to block you to keep you where you
are and keep you from beginning to
develop your true greatness always some
fear how do we handle it
and I'm saying that if you've been
hiding out behind but
if you've been using the fact that you
don't have enough money or you don't
have the education take it head on go
get the education I'll sing to a guy the
other day who was saying he I said how
old are you he says 47 years old I said
your sister tell me that you can't read
he said that's right I said why
well you know I I didn't go to school
excuse me how old are you I'm 47 47 yes
and you can't read or write yes have you
ever heard of adult school adult
education
have you decided that
you should learn how to read to begin to
expand your world why are you using that
as a racket
why don't you decide now that you're
going to expand your world that if other
people can learn you could learn too
well it's hard for me how do you have
you been and sit in a class yet have you
signed up yet no I haven't
see a lot of people say no ladies and
gentlemen to things and they don't even
know what they're saying no to
haven't even challenged themselves he
hasn't even gone to sit into a class and
say teach me how to read instead it's
been easier for him to go through life
he thinks
trying to play a whole con game
pretending he knows how to do something
that he doesn't know how to do and you
know what most of us go through life
like that
most of us go through life pretending
pretending that we're satisfied where we
are pretending that everything is okay
pretending that that we don't have any
special goals or Ambitions or desires
when really deep down inside we do
really want more but if you look at our
Behavior if you judge based upon what we
do
that really will tell you some true
stories about people because you have to
judge a tree by the fruit it bears not
the fruit that it talks about see a lot
of people pretend that they want more
out of life but all you have to do is
watch their actions that will tell you
something so I used to pretend that I
want to lose weight but how could you
tell I was pretending
watch me when I have a piece of sweet
potato pie
within walking distance of some peanuts
some potato chips see I was pretending
that I really wanted to lose weight no
all you do is watch what I eat I tell
you what I'm seriously committed to
people tell you oh yeah one day I want
to have a restaurant see they're
pretending they want to go into business
for themselves they're not serious how
can you tell Les watch their actions
watch what they're doing the proof is in
the pudding so if you want to do
something if you've thought about
something you want to do take it head on
decide that you're going to start
looking at it start doing research on it
start tackling it start becoming
involved in whatever and wherever it
might lead you to begin to explore the
possibilities in that particular thing
that you're seeking so that you can
begin to learn all you can about it
decide that you're going to face it that
whatever shortcomings you have that
you're going to strengthen yourself
there whatever training that's required
that you're going to go get that
training that you're going to get
started right now the George Washington
Carver would say do what you can where
you are with what you have and never be
satisfied let's be fully used to say it
I heard Joe Dudley talk about always
strive to be more than that which you
are yeah don't get satisfied with
yourself always know that wherever you
are you can enjoy more that you deserve
more but most people you know what they
do most people go through life quietly
and safely tiptoeing to an early grade
find out what it is you want and go
after it as if your life depends on it
why because it does
people that have found their passion
people that found the things that they
love people that have found the things
that they can pour their lives into
those people live longer I was in New
York and I had to do a seminar at a
special church and a guy by the name of
Reverend Johnny Young Blood and I said
how is it that you were able to build
this big housing facility and got all of
the various community and religious
groups together to to have this dwelling
for 2 000 residents that were were once
homeless how were you able to take on
this responsibility wasn't it
overwhelming he said the kind of work I
do he said it's in me I've got to live
what's in me
and I think that's everybody's desire in
life you've got to live what's in your
life is just too short and unpredictable
but what are what do we say but but
there always be tomorrow
oh no
there's no guarantees you're going to
show up tomorrow there are a lot of
people who were here yesterday that
they're not here today there are a lot
of opportunities that were around
yesterday they're not here today oh you
can wait but you know what Abraham
Lincoln said well good things might come
to those of two who wait but only the
things that have been left over by those
who Hustle foreign
[Applause]
you deserve much more than that the
leftovers that somebody has left you so
take it head on begin to explore here's
something else
decide to do it now
decide whatever you want to do that you
are now going to become actively
involved right now exploring the
possibilities for you that you're going
to look at it and do just a little bit
of it right now when I decided to become
a speaker I didn't just quit my job and
just ran out and say I'm a motivational
speaker no what I did was I decided to
start looking at other people that were
involved in the speaking profession I
volunteered to work with some speakers
so that I could learn whatever you want
to do get your feet wet gain some
experience doing some volunteer work in
the area and find out whether or not
this thing you want to do will fit for
you A friend of mine told me he wanted
to have a restaurant and say have you
ever operated a restaurant before he
said no I said well really you don't
even know if you want one I said what's
your expertise what do you bring to the
table he said I can cook real good I
said well what about the management side
what about the business part of the
restaurant you're not going to be
cooking all the time somebody's got to
receive the money who's going to manage
the Personnel he said you got it right
you got a point there so this guy got a
job in a restaurant in the evening time
on a part-time basis after doing that
for a while he said you know what I
think I just want to be a chef
he said after working their people
didn't show up to work he said it's hard
to find to help people were responsible
the headaches the guests was just giving
him problems day in and day out they
weren't ever satisfied he said no I just
think I'll stick the cooking
see you got to find out what fits for
you because you might decide after you
go up in there and examine it and
experience it and and get some
experience on the about on it well you
say this is really not what I want this
does not fit for me so decide that
you're going to do that now John H
Johnson said something that's very
important he said there's no defense
against an Excellence that meets
oppressing public need see whatever you
decide to do look at it and find out
what is it that I have that I could
bring to the table that can begin to
enable me to ensure that I could be
successful in this where is the opening
for you there's room for you out here
out here in the arena call life there's
room for you to come out and live your
dream don't allow but to keep you in the
corner or keep you up in the bleaches
looking at life being a spectator not
being a participant making a difference
in life I believe that all of us came
here with something all of us showed up
to give something and that nobody but
nobody is going to give that service
that you have to give no one's going to
produce your product no one's going to
write your book no one's going to open
your Academy no one's going to begin to
create your daycare with a special
curriculum to help to cultivate the high
self-esteem in our children that's your
idea and if you don't bring your idea
out here when you die all of us will
suffer because we've been deprived of
your Genius because you're allowed but
to keep you in the bleachers and not
pursuing your greatness you take it to
your grave with you and that's what most
people do
I think that's why the guy said that
many people died at age 21.
and don't get buried until they're 65.
they're walking dead
you can tell them by the way they walk
how they look in the face when they
speak to you I was giving a speech at
this high school and a lady came after
school she said Mr Brown
to you about my son I said what is it
she said he's not motivated
you got to have energy ladies and
gentlemen you've got to have life if you
excited about what you're doing even in
the area of selling you know people
don't buy because of logical reasoning
people buy because of your way of
feeling people are like to be around
dead people
oh no Let the dead bury the dead no no
keep them away from before they grab you
or to hold on to you
so the fact that that whatever you do
you want to be excited about it you want
to have the kind of excitement that is
so contagious that people want to be
around you because whatever you're doing
whatever you talk to people about this
particular idea that you have they're
looking at you and they want to know do
you believe it and are you the kind of
person they want to be in business with
and if you're not positive if you're not
energetic if you're not fired up about
it how can you expect anybody else to be
fired up about your idea am I right
all right repeat after me please I'm
going to be fired up about my dream
put his hand on your right a little say
you got what it takes
there are a lot of people
who say but I tried once or twice
and it didn't work out
and so they used that as an excuse not
to ever come out again
guy said um if at first you don't
succeed you're running about average
and it didn't work out two or three
times
well that's all right you're running
about average you know I heard something
a jarring question it says why is it
that people prefer known Hells to
unknown heavens
[Music]
you know why because it's comfortable
ladies and gentlemen I remember I was in
um a service once and I heard Dr Johnny
Coleman give this example she talked
about
a man who had been captured behind the
Enemy Lines in a war and was sentenced
to to be killed or another option the
captain said to the guy listen he said
tomorrow morning at six o'clock you can
face the firing squad or you can go out
this door over here
and the guy said
what's out the door
he said no one knows all we can tell you
just unknown Horrors
he thought and the next morning he
selected the firing squad
after the shots rang out
the captain's secretary said what's
beyond that door and he said
freedom
but very few people would select to do
it because it's unknown
see a lot of people
never lived their dreams
a lot of people never do the things they
want to do a lot of people stay on jobs
where they're miserable I read an
article call is your job making you sick
a lot of people some of y'all know about
that already here
they're going to say Amen it's all right
that one lady told me she said Les I
when I used to go to work she said when
I stepped in the door felt like a
refrigerator dropped on my shoulders
how many of y'all understand that kind
of feeling
just hated to go
around the afternoon or come Monday
morning my head used to thrive I just
couldn't take it didn't want to go
sometimes just just for the heck of it I
just drive on by laughs
I used to hate to go to work
many of us choose an active living death
many of us are Walking Dead The Walking
Dead that we're not doing what we want
to do many of us stay in relationships
where we're dying together
rather than growing and expanding and
living together
we're miserable but because we don't
have the courage
to see ourselves beyond that
relationship that has turned toxic
we go through life living dead people
and you can always tell couples that
have been together for a little while
going to restaurant the one sitting side
by side giggling and talking to each
other feeding each other with their
focused food they just got together for
one week
you see him in the car they're sitting
on all each other hugging his [ __ ] or
they've been together about three days
all right
but if you see peoples in the restaurant
to you know see a couple and they're
sitting in front of each other
take so long for this food I wonder when
they go hurry up
those are the maribus
for years let me
well it's cheaper to keep but not
necessarily
it's according to the price you want to
pay see the price of Peace of Mind the
price of living the truth of being
honest with yourself and say wait a
minute it's got to be more than this
so you've got to decide wait wait
even if I I things don't work out even
if I experience defeat a failure that
does not make me a failure
it's a difference between failing and
being a failure
if you if things don't work out if you
don't produce the results you want
that's all but don't confuse who you are
with the results that you produce I used
to be a state legislator in Columbus
Ohio and I remember once I was going to
introduce some legislation on the floor
and after getting that legislation
passed a guy came up behind me and he
had some legislation that I opposed him
on that and I was about to stand up to
debate this guy and the guy next to me
said excuse don't don't debate that guy
why do you know who that is I said no
it's wilkoski from Toledo it's a bad
dude he's a lawyerless that man can
debate I don't care I'm Les Brown maybe
Brown's ball
come on
so I raise my hand Mr Speaker you said
the gentleman from the 29th house
district said yes sir to tell the
gentleman I like to take him on
challenge him on this legislation he
said well because you said I would more
than like to Mr Speaker everybody would
say whoa
I asked him some questions he responded
I say I wonder why I asked that man that
question
wilkoski won't be out
I mean I was so embarrassed I just
lifted back to my room with my yes I can
add it
whatever here's what I learned when you
win see if I win a debate I win because
of what I know when I lose I lose
because what I don't know
so I had to check out what is it that I
did not know I wasn't prepared I did not
do enough research I did not do my
homework so he handled me like he wanted
to so I came back again I waited on to
my other legislation did my homework but
he was more than able to take me out
again but pretty soon each time it would
take him it would become a little bit
more difficult and a little bit more
difficult and the older guys say would
you argue on behalf of this legislation
for me I said sure I start volunteering
to do work in the legislative committees
for the older guys I said absolutely and
the more I did it the better I became
and then people began to start
respecting me and when I would ask and
say Mr Speaker I like to speak on that
bill some guys let's start trembling and
stuff like Jimmy I don't know
do we have a problem here
but if I wasn't willing to be humiliated
if I wasn't willing to allow myself to
be embarrassed if I wasn't willing to be
debated and defeated if I wasn't willing
to look at it and say well I'm just not
good as I'm going to be you want that
lady to say Lord I ain't what I want to
be what I'm going to be but thank God I
sure ain't what it was you can either
live your dreams
or live your fears
and I think the majority of people
actually are not living their dreams but
are living their fears
so I want to ask you a question
what are your fears
what are you afraid of
what are you scared of
because we all have fears don't we
we all have something that's blocking us
that's holding us back
and as we begin to look at life what we
realize is that the reason that most
people are not living out their true
potential
and not doing all of the things that
they would really like to do
is because of fear
some people call fear
false evidence or expectations appearing
real
are reminded of the story of a guy
that was living in an area where he had
some new neighbors and these neighbors
had a bulldog
and when he came home every day
this Bulldog used to chase him about a
half a block from his house every day he
would have to streak home I mean he
would just run this Bulldog be right on
his heels and so he just got tired of
that because he would go home and about
a half a block away from home he would
look around for this bulldog and he
would see him and he would go walking
casually long and this Bulldog come out
of nowhere
and start chasing him he'd run home so
this one day he just got tired and so
when the Bulldog was running after him
he started running he saw a rock and he
stopped to pick it up to throw at the
bulldog and when the Bulldog got up on
him he started barking he realized the
Bulldog would have any teeth in his
mouth
then he's not chasing the Bulldog if you
don't get all the way
because the boss the Bulldog could have
done his gum you know
and so you know what most people go
through life Running Scared
Running Scared from things that have no
teeth in them
because their false expectations
appearing real let's see we're brilliant
enough to scare ourselves to death you
realize that there are some people
actually who get a kick out of scaring
themselves to death
I remember the last frightening movie I
saw it was The Exorcist I will never
forget
when I came home I'll never
end I had already called my former wife
and said listen turn the lights on
I was coming in the driveway and I and I
was getting out of the car and all of a
sudden I couldn't get out I started
blowing my heart I said Madeline they
got me they got me she came to the
kitchen and said take your seatbelt
loose food
foreign
but there are a lot of people who they
get off on that they love I'm a person
not I my brother is a paratrooper my
twin brother he's in the military career
man
I would love to jump out of an airplane
to parachute I'm scared though
I mean I really admire my brother for
that I would really love to be macho man
like that what are the things that you
fear
that's been keeping you from living your
dream that's been keeping you from doing
some things that you would like to do
just think about those things
and how do we begin to handle that
Abraham Maslow said that the life is
about growth and he said you could
either go back to your comfort zone and
there you won't find any growth or
you must really be willing to go forward
and face your fears again and again and
again because you're never going to have
a fear-free existence I mean some fear
is acceptable and legitimate there are
some things that you you really should
be afraid of now you shouldn't allow it
to immobilize you you acknowledge it you
take it into account and you carry
yourself accordingly there are times
that we should proceed with caution but
it's the difference between
being stopped by fear is the difference
between having a fear and the fear
having you
so what do we do one acknowledge it
and knowing that it's okay
don't condemn yourself
for being afraid
it's perfectly
fine to have some fears you acknowledge
your fears you Embrace those fears and
then you move on you act on whatever it
is that you fear because once you
embrace it see what you resist will
persist what you resist will persist so
one of the most important things is is
to begin to embrace your fear the fear
of bodily harm that's legitimate when I
was a disc jockey in Columbus Ohio
you know I was young about 22 23. I
thought I was tough
and I was on the air and Al Green who
was a great performer at that time and
still is now now singing gospel music
had a record his first hit record was
backup trade
so a guy came in the town and was
impersonating Al Green I happened to
know Al Green because I'd already booked
him and so when I found out this guy was
impersonating Al Green I came on the air
and did an editorial about it and I
exposed it he was rather a big fellow
and so he had the word out
that when I see this guy let's find the
disc jock I'm going to knock him in
mouth of having a big mouth
so I was driving down Main Street in
Columbus Ohio had my son in a car and I
always had the little saying hey if
anybody ever put a thread on with me I'm
gonna make him honor it so I saw this
guy in the street so I pull around I say
excuse me I'll be right back got out of
the car I said hey man I heard you said
that you were looking for me I'm Les
Brown he said you are I said yeah I said
what is it I'm the one that said that
you were an imposter I said I want to
know what you're going to do about it he
opened his coat he had a gun there I say
but whatever I said to hurt your
feelings
foreign
yourself accordingly
and do what makes sense for you
well one major fear I've always had is a
fear of a dentist
and this fear had me I didn't have that
fear and what really reinforced it you
got to watch things that can feed your
fear I saw a movie that most people
would not remember this movie was
starring Dustin Hoffman it's called the
marathon man with Lawrence Olivier I
mean he's trying to get a confession out
of here and he took this drill out let
me tell you something he went in duffman
Hoffman's mouth with that drill I had a
dollar worth of popcorn
that popcorn with everyone
I could not go to the dentist for five
for five years I had left broadcasting
went to the Ohio legislature had an
impacted wisdom tooth now that hurts
and I would call as soon as the people
would answer the phone I would hang up
that's not frightening with Dr hamler's
Office boom right here then I got to the
point where I could just ask for an
appointment hello and I wouldn't give my
real name
because I knew I wasn't gonna keep it
I'd give anybody's name Joe jiggly Jim
it did better and pretty soon I got to
the point where I could give my name it
was about four years after that you know
I said my name is Les Brown then I would
call back and say look here due to my
legislative agenda I won't be able to
make it
so the lady finally said on phone said
you're scared aren't you I said no I'm
not she said then why don't you come in
I said that's none of your business
she said you're not coming in because
you're scared I wish you just would not
waste our time and she hung up I said
you have no right to do that to people
like me you know so finally it'll make
it long and short of it I was hurting so
bad I said wait a minute I've got to do
something and I said what am I afraid of
go there and handle I said man I said Dr
Hamlet I just can't hear this drill I
mean if you can do whatever I just don't
I don't need to hear this drill this
drill that sound you know that's the
what gets me that drill don't pull that
drill out on me
he said just calm down calm down and it
wasn't really bad as I thought it was
one of the things you find out that when
you face your fears is not as bad as you
think it is and when people tell you I
just can't do it I I can't handle I mean
really really I can't handle it what
they're envisioning is that they're not
going to be if they're going to clock
out like you're going to die
and guess what we all had occasions when
we confronted our fears we had to do
something we felt uncomfortable with we
didn't want to do it and we did not die
they didn't come take us and put us in a
box somewhere am I right
so what we've got to begin to do how do
we handle that what's the process
because it's all up in here one I think
is imagine the worst case scenario I
just imagine that he went in my mouth
and with this drill and that I just
croaked out
then I imagine that's the worst case
scenario then I had another technique I
used visualize yourself being more than
able and capable of handling it I used
to have a tremendous inferiority complex
about speaking before people that I felt
who had more going for them than I did
because I'm not College trained I used
to feel that college people were the
most intelligent people on the planet
and there was nothing I had to say for
them
and what will that what will they listen
to me for that's the way I felt and so I
had to to visualize myself
speaking before them speaking before
various audiences that had more going
for them than I did and realize and
appreciate my own value and that I was a
worthwhile person even though I didn't
have all going for me I didn't have the
money I didn't have the education that
they had so part of the process is
seeing yourself being worthy being
capable having what you need to make you
a worthwhile person and that you're more
than able and that you deserve to be
listened to or you deserve to have that
dream and that passion and whatever it
is that you see and envision there
you've got to see it in your mind's eye
and know that you've got what it takes
repeat after me please I must see
and my mind's eye
see myself
confronting my fears
handling my fears I'm more than able
Shake somebody's hand on your right and
left and say you got the right stuff
so deciding as you look at your life as
you look into the future and say what
fears am I holding on to
what fears that I'm allowing to imprison
me
that's keeping me from breaking out
that's keeping me from living up to my
true potential that's keeping me from
really being happy that's keeping me
from having a sense of adventure and
excitement in my life
what's what's keeping me from
controlling my destiny what fears
that I'm giving that permission to
notice what I said
that we must give our permission
to fear to immobilize us
because whatever discomfort you
experience
whatever challenges a difficulty that it
is
you got to handle it
you've got to go up in there and wrestle
with it will it be easy no
will it be challenging yes
a friend of mine who's going into
recovery he's been addicted to crack
cocaine for years and alcohol
he was talking about how challenging it
was and why he was dreading going on
going into cold turkey
I said what do you want me to tell you
that is going to be a picnic no it's not
it's going to kick your butt yes it is
are you going to want to die yes yes
that's a part of it but that's just what
you must go through in order to get
where you want to go and guess what you
are strong enough to do it
you're strong enough and your life is
worth whatever you have to go through
to get past this addiction whatever you
have to do this dream you got whatever
you want to do will it be easy to just
run out there and do it no will it
happen overnight no
would it be a struggle yes will there be
times when you can't make ends meet yes
that's a part of it will there be times
you won't know what to do yes that's a
part of it
well you have some opposition will
things go wrong sometimes you will have
many visits from Murphy foreign
don't worry
somebody must have told us some place
along the line I don't know where but
somebody must have told people oh life
is going to be real easy
if they told you that I've got a special
announcement they lied
never forget I had a special piece of
legislation I wanted to get passed and I
said to her guys look can I count on
your vote he said yes and look here if I
can't count on let me know there's
another guy that owes me a chip and I
can call on that and I won't need your
vote but I do need it if you say you're
going to do it do it
you say you can count on it legislation
came up he voted against my bill my bill
passed I went back to and said hey I
told you I needed the vote but if you
couldn't give it up let me know I would
get somebody else said why did you tell
me he said I lied
I was in shock
how many of you that life just wore you
out that you didn't expect that you
thought you'd go to school get good
grades get a job and you came out here
and you'll be able to get a job a little
happily ever afterward you say they lied
you know
yes they did they never told me you know
that song said mama told me there'll be
days like this
I don't even tell us that
something about life is challenging I
mean it's some stuff you get out here
you didn't read it in a book nowhere did
nobody warn you that it was gonna come
down on you like this it's called life
there are kind of challenges like that
so what's the the next piece is that you
accept yourself then you accept the fear
as a fact and not a force see when you
accept yourself and you accept fear as a
fact that means that it's something that
happens it's something that you're going
to experience but it is not a force to
hold you back it doesn't have any
special power other than that that you
give it so you accept the fact that you
are afraid
and then you move on anyhow
you move on past it and you do whatever
you've got to do I was in a big
motivational rally for a gentleman by
the name of Dexter Yeager down in the
Carolinas I was standing backstage and I
had to go out I was the last speak on
the program at the first time I'd been
in a stadium of this size over 10 000
people you couldn't see the people
because the lights are just blaring in
your eyes called free enterprise day I
was afraid my heart was beating fast I'm
just pacing back and forth and Dexter
said are you all right I said yeah
thank you
yeah all right so I said wait a minute
just calm down calm yourself hold me
hold it it's all right Les it's all
right all right just be as scared as you
can be
I'm gonna say Embrace that fear just try
and see how scared you can really get
and stop breathing deeper
so the guy came back and said are you
about to die
I said no I'm fine but after I start
embracing it and trying to make myself
as a friend as I can get and imagine
what's the worst thing that I could go
out there and do my mind go Blake and I
fade on stage then the longer they gave
me my check
thank you
so once I started laughing at myself I
started talking to myself and say you
know you scared today
and I said I just calm myself down and I
went out there and I cooked
and that's what you got to do I had
another experience where I was at a
major corporation and I was it was one
of my first major presentations I was
going to do for this Corporation and I
had four other presenters that had large
firms and one of the things that you've
got to do is you've got to watch your
inner conversation and discipline your
thinking and your imagination because if
you don't your mind will take you on a
wild trip
so my mind said hey Les I said what
these guys are going to wipe you out you
can't compete with them because I heard
these guys sitting over a cross from me
and they were talking about all that
they had going for them and so I started
doubting myself and I became afraid and
I was thinking well maybe I shouldn't go
in there
and so I knew then and this is what I
suggest to you sometimes you got to talk
to yourself talking to yourself you know
it could be a good exercise might be the
only intelligent conversation you ever
get foreign
I started talking to myself said let's
find let me tell you something
you care about these guys and their
firms and all their money you you got
six children
you got a mama you got to take care of
homes you ain't got nothing to lose
I win that room and looked at those
people I said don't you do nothing till
you hear from me
and I got that contract too
so when you have your lower self talking
to you telling you what you can't do
part of what you've got to do is be your
own motivator you can you can't talk
casually to yourself you can't say I sit
down you must calm down now
no that's unconscious mind won't hear
that you've got to have a good
conversation to you so hey and answer
yourself too don't pay these people any
attention you answer yourself hey what
you gonna do I'm going in get off all
right very good go in there and take
care of business you've got to talk to
yourself and you build yourself up and
you'll feel your energy level coming up
and people will feel that around you see
now if you go through life being afraid
people can sense that
they can pick up that fear so that's why
you've got to stand up inside yourself
I'm reminded of the little boy that was
on a bus and and some bigger fellows
were picking at him you know and so he
he wanted to move from by then they were
thumping him on the head and so he stood
up just to get from by them and they
would push him back down and he would
stand up again they'd push him back down
and he stood up again they pushed it on
held him down he said you might hold me
down but I'm standing up inside myself
and that's what you got to do in life
see when you are not filling your life
with the things that you are capable of
doing see we all have some stuff that
we've been given
and I don't think
that it's optional for us to sit on what
we have
see if you're sitting on what you have
what you've been given and I think
everybody's been given something
to bring to the planet that only you can
do that only you can perform that only
you can initiate that activity
and if you don't do that if you're not
filling in your life with your life work
or your mission
then there are gaps in your life and
what we do when we're not living out our
true identity
we begin to fill the gaps we fill the
holes with garbage
alcohol
drugs worry
self-destructive Behavior
so when you begin to look at your life
and you know that that you're not doing
what you can do because you have allowed
yourself to be held captive by your
fears now
when you don't have a true appreciation
an acceptance for who you are
and you allow yourself to be immobilized
by fear what happens in the process is
that you begin to abuse yourself
you begin to sabotage your life you
begin to sabotage your dreams you begin
to unconsciously work against yourself
you become Your Own Worst Enemy so what
do you do about that well you you begin
to realize that your dream
and your gifts
have so much meaning and so much value
for you till your hunger for them
will begin to push you past the fear
you're hunger to have them
will give you a special Drive
as you work on yourself as you begin to
acknowledge your true identity the true
power that you have the true capacity
you have to bring about change the
miracle working power that you have
within yourself
to do the things that you want to do
when you take them on I'm reminded of a
man who
this gentleman
was doing a special study of a special
tribe in Africa Headhunters
and he had difficulty in developing a
relationship with these tribesmen
because of the fact that he had fear he
had fear they would take his head
a day off fears aren't bad
I was a legitimate fear
that's a good fear to give you a
headache
so he worked there for a long time with
no effort no progress
in developing relationship and Rapport
and being able to achieve a level of
trust
so finally one night while he was in bed
he was thinking about I said what what
is it that you came here to do what is
your life work as a missionary he said I
wanted to study these tribesmen
I said what's the worst thing that they
can do to you
kill you
and he just decided hey this is what I
came here to do I know that there's some
risk involved and I'm going to do it
come with me
he said I'm not going to be afraid
anymore
he went back the next day
and he started doing the work and trying
to talk to an interview many of the
members of this tribe
and they began to respond to him they
throughout the welcome mat to him and
years later when people came to see what
his progress was
they asked him
how were you able to do this how did you
convert the relationship from being
hostile
to that of being positive and he said
something I think his value for all of
us
he said when life can no longer threaten
you with death
he said what else is there
what else is there
and the majority of the fears that we
have are not life or death fears they're
not those kind of fears
but through our imagination
we blow them out of proportion
and we give them more power than they
actually have or deserve
and we permit them to govern Our Lives
we permit them to determine how far we
can stretch out on our dreams and
discovering our stuff
and as we begin to look at ourselves and
and begin to wait a minute
just getting to the point
as you assess yourself and and begin to
prove yourself and just say wait hold a
minute hold a minute I've been sweating
this out
what can what's the worst thing that can
happen to me on this
will it kill me will I die why am I
going through all of these changes over
this
how much power does this really have and
am I the one that's feeding the power
into it see a lot of times we we allow
ourselves to be fed and to be
programming to to being afraid you watch
the news and read the newspaper you'll
be scared to come out the house
am I right
you'd be afraid
so what kinds of things what kinds of
thoughts are you feeding your
Consciousness what kind of things are
you putting in your mind that will
enable you to either move forward or to
justify why you are staying where you
are
another piece that I look at that when I
finally decided
that I was going to go to the dentist
the pain was so great I couldn't hold
out any longer all of a sudden the fear
didn't matter
I can't even take me
now some people need fear you know have
a friend that that we told him hey man
you know you need to lose some weight
you're getting overweight and out of
shape and at all age we need to have a
regular program and Bud said man I've
been fat since I was a little boy I'm
you know I'm big boned I've never seen a
fat skeleton though
well
Bud became ill
how many of you ever see the fat
skeleton right yeah I know all right but
became ill passed out
and um I was there and the doctor was
talking to him
and Bob I think was going to go right
back to same old eating habits and doing
everything you know there's a look here
um you are a diabetic
and so now here's some of the side
effects you know you could go blind you
can become an amputee none of that
touched him he said you can become
impotent he said what did you say
[Applause]
God has lost weight he exercises every
day he's in a body sculpture
48 years young he looks great I can't
believe but just that one statement
made all the difference in the world but
as a new man today
so what is it that has to happen to you
some people don't take corrective
measures to improve their health until
they get a pronouncement that they're
about to die then they'll start okay all
right I'm ready to do whatever you want
me to do but they won't do that they can
see people dropping off like flies
around them well that's them you got to
go from something
we go through life really blocking
ourselves constantly and fears one of
the the greatest instruments that we
could use to stifle our true potential
when you begin to to look at your life
you can decide to to use fear as a
blocker or you can decide to use it as
building blocks that you decide hey look
here I'm going to move in this direction
I'm not going to allow anything to stop
me from doing what I want to do re-shake
somebody's hand on your right and left
and say I'm unstoppable
foreign
and you go forth anyhow
you go forth in a spirit
and a knowing
that there's a way that you can begin to
handle this there's a way
out here somewhere there's a solution
what it is that you're seeking that you
have the capacity to whatever comes up
to handle it to face it and rather than
feeling powerless
you begin to feel powerful
see when all of the major downsizings
that are taking place around this
country there are a lot of people who
are biting their fingers in fear
that they might lose their jobs
but there are a few people who have
decided within themselves I'm going to
make it some people aren't waiting to be
cut
some people are moving on their own
because they feel within themselves I've
got what it takes to make it
They're Not Afraid about tomorrow
because of how they see themselves
because of what they feel that they
deserve because of what they feel that
they can create for themselves because
these people have decided as they look
at the future as they look at themselves
there's a way where there's a will
there's a way for me to begin to create
a way out of no way
and when you have that kind of
Consciousness when you have that kind of
spirit nothing can stop you
nothing
what would your life be like
as you look toward the future if you
decided I'm not going to allow my fears
to stop me
what would your life be like
what would your future be like if you
decided to to want that which you desire
so strongly
that It prepares you past your fears
that you experience the fear as the one
book says Feel the fear and do it anyway
what would your life be like
and I'm saying to you
that all of us who have been entombed by
fear
have the capacity to resurrect ourselves
and to resurrect our dreams all of us
have a capacity to do that
and you have is it easy no
it's not easy
can I do it yes
what's one of the ways to get started
some of us need somebody to hold our
hands
sometimes we need somebody to help us
out be willing to say I don't know be
willing to reach out be willing to get
some assistance
to take you to the next level of what
great athlete you never expect boxes to
make profound statements I think it was
Joe Frazier said this one he says all of
us are like the blind man at some point
in our lives standing on the corner
waiting for somebody to lead us across
to all of us at some point in our lives
need some help need someone to reach out
to us to throw out the lifeline to help
us go across some treacherous Waters
that we couldn't navigate by ourselves
none of us do it by ourselves all of us
at some point of Our Lives we need that
kind of help we need that kind of
assistance because we grow from the
people we have in our lives that can
enrich our lives personally
professionally spiritually and all the
dimensions of Our Lives we don't grow in
a vacuum
so as you look at yourself what are the
fears you have that maybe you need some
help
and strengthening yourself in that area
as you assess your strengths and your
weaknesses as you begin to approve
yourself and your passions and your
dreams and your goals and the things
that you want if you decide to
experience all of your true potential as
you decide to manifest all of your
greatness
as you decide wait a minute what what
else is available to me out here if I
decided to experience the fear of
rejection the fear of no the fear of
failure
the fear of standing by myself what else
is available of taking a chance a fear
of losing it all what else is available
to me that will bring some extra meaning
and value
the fear of people not liking me you
know how many people do things they
don't want to do because they want
everybody to like them
everybody's not going to like you
excuse me special announcement
everybody's not going to like you
no that's it's just not that kind of
world what but you know a lot of people
who won't take positions on issues who
won't take a stand for things they
believe in who won't speak up for
themselves because they don't want to
make anybody mad
oh it was Bill Cosby he said I don't
know secret of success is he said but
but he said trying to please everybody
you can't please everybody
but there are people who have a fear of
rocking the boat
so they just go alone in life just go
alone well how do you feel well I don't
really want to say
how many of you know people like that
raise your hand they these people are
living life they're not truly
experiencing life what do you really
want to do well I don't like this but I
guess I'll go ahead on and do no the
life is too short for that too short and
unpredictable mosing through
not trying to disturb anything not
trying to shake anything up not trying
to make any waves
you see there are some people who who
come through the universe and their
level of contribution and the level of
energy they manifest is so small so
inconspicuous that when they go you
won't even know they left
I mean they're people who die on jobs
and and you say Hey where's John oh
John's been dead six miles
you're kidding no is that right yeah
I didn't know why did somebody say well
I guess we didn't miss him but there's
some people because of their personality
because of their contribution because of
their the investment of their time and
their energy and the impact they have
there that when they go everybody will
miss them so when Mother Teresa checks
out everybody will know when Rosa Parks
everybody will know Nelson Mandela
everybody will know why because of their
contribution
see but there's some people because
their contribution is so small
no one will care
some saying before you are boxed and
buried
decide that you're gonna box and bury
your fears
decide that you're going to begin to
live life on a new level seeking out New
Horizons that you're going to find more
love and more joy and more ways to give
more to life God said something I love
this he says everything a man does for
himself
guess what
he takes with him but everything he does
for others he leaves behind
so when you begin to say what is it that
I want to leave
what contribution that I want to begin
to make what difference do I want to
make in life
what is it that I want to do with the
rest of the life that I have left what
what chances I need to take what risk do
I need to begin to embrace what fears do
I need to step on
what areas of my life am I dead right
now what dream you can either Live Your
Dreams or live your fears you have got
to get to a point where you say I'm sick
and tired of living like this there's
got to be more
that's see that's when people go out and
strike out on their dreams that's when
people get out of relationships where
they're dying together rather than
growing together that's where they leave
Johnson where you going away from here I
don't know
good
foreign
do you have another job no I don't how
are you going to make it I don't know
but I will
see you will when you put yourself in
that kind of situation I'm reminded of
two frogs that that were hopping down
the road and they they fell into a
bottle of milk and one was hopping up
and down for a while and he drowned he
just gave up but this other frog gets
kept on kicking he wouldn't give up he
just kept on kicking and pretty soon he
churned that milk into butter and he
walked on it foreign
slap your wife and knock you down I said
just keep on kicking you know and you
can kick on out of those circumstances
whatever they are not be intimidated by
them most people are not accumulating
wealth most people are living in poverty
most people are living far below their
potential not because they don't have
the capacity not because they have not
been given Authority and dominion over
everything on the face of the Earth
but most people are living like they're
living because of the fact that they
don't believe they can have any more
than what they now have
the book called The miseducation of the
new
ecology Woodson said if you can
determine what a man shall think you'll
never have to concern yourself with what
he will do if you can make a man feel
inferior you'd never have to compel him
to seek an inferior status for he will
seek it himself and if you can make a
man feel
cast you have to order him to go to the
back door he'll go without being told
and if there's no door his very nature
will demand one
that's why scripture reminds us being
not conformed to this world but be ye
transformed by the renewing of your mind
every day you have to sell yourself
find those old thoughts that old belief
system every day you've got to sell
yourself on that it's possible
that you got to put a new mind in you
you got to get out of your mind you got
to begin to restructure your thinking
every day you've got to begin to
recondition your mind see many of us go
through life making choices thinking
it's our choices and it's not what do
you mean by that a reminder of the great
Anthropologist Margaret Mead she was in
a restaurant in Europe and a waiter saw
her and said oh how are you I'm so glad
to see you he said there are several
other Americans here tonight and she
said is that right
he said yes he's she said when you
served in dessert let me know and I'll
tell you exactly how many are here
he said that's not possible she said let
me know after you serve dessert when he
served dessert he came back and he told
her she got up she walked around and she
looked and she observed and she said you
have exactly 65 Americans here he
checked the guest list and he was amazed
he said how did you know that
she said because
in Europe when you eat a slice of pie or
cake you eat it from the back toward the
tip in America when we eat a slice of
pie of cake we eat it from the tip
toward the back how many of you when you
eat a slice of pie cake you eat it from
the tip toward the back raise your hands
please good now what else is in your
mind
what else are you doing unconsciously
that you don't even know I'm going to
say something and I want you to answer
it after it I want you to end it for me
Winston tastes good like what
how many of you don't even smoke Winston
but know it raise your hands please now
that commercial been off the air for 30
30 years
share something with you the easiest
thing I've ever done was to earn a
million dollars
the most difficult thing I've ever done
was to believe
it happened to me
difficult part
to believe that given my circumstances
if my birth parents came down this aisle
right now I would not know either one if
my daddy came up here or my mother came
up here given the fact that I was born
in abandoned building on a floor being
labeled educable mentally [ __ ] not
having any college training I used to
feel all my life
but people who had college degrees were
more intelligent than me I remember
going to see the late Dr Norman Vincent
Peale the author of the book power of
positive thinking and I used to look at
him up on stage and I said I could do
that I would love to talk to people I
love to talk to people and I said I can
do that
but then when I started going back to my
car
my mental conditioning activated itself
and it said Les Brown you can't do that
you don't have a college education let's
find you can't do that you don't have
the training you've never worked for a
major corporation you can't do that what
makes you think you can earn 5 10 15 20
000 in an hour you don't earn that now
working for two or three months what
makes you think that you can speak for
at T Procter Gamble McDonald's
Corporation General Electric these are
clients I have now you you've never even
worked for them how many have you ever
thought about something you wanted to do
and you talk yourself out of it raise
your hand if you know what I'm talking
about that inner conversation is what's
going to haunt you after standing here
and saying I can do all things in Christ
who strengthens me after saying that
again and again we are more than
conquerors that inner conversation will
cause you when you leave here to go back
leading a life of mediocrity leading a
life of unproductivity leading a life of
poverty so I'm going to share with you
how to break out of that foreign
[Applause]
I want to share with you how to reach
your goals I think the Bible's greatest
motivation book ever been written
now I want you to repeat after me please
we got to recondition our minds first
let us say together good things that's
supposed to happen to me
and Don I want you to say that to
yourself every day see we live in a
world where we believe that bad things
are supposed to happen to us I remember
the point of my life Bishop when things
are going good for me and I said this is
too good to be true something is bound
to happen guess what it did thou shall
decree a thing that shall be established
unto you and shall accomplish that where
until it has been sent watch your words
and watch what you say about yourself
about your Affairs be conscious of that
on a daily basis why because your words
are powerful in the beginning was the
word life and death is in the tongue
watch what you say never say I'm broke
say I'm overcoming a cash flow problem
foreign
[Applause]
what you want not what you don't want
so affirm good things as opposed to
happen to me and begin to believe that
begin to expect that
now
I was talking to my
oldest son
Calvin we're going for a walk
and I said Calvin do you want to be
successful he said yes sir Dad
it's okay we kept on walking
then I stopped and I looked him in the
eyes
it's my namesake my junior
I said Calvin we're looking at each
other
do you expect to be successful
given the fact that you are a single
parent of two kids
given the fact that you decided not to
go to college to further your education
given the fact that you are very
talented but you're behind on your
dreams and your bills do expect based
upon your performance based upon what
you produce at this point in time in
your life do you expect to be successful
and Calvin got quiet
because see if you ask most people at
the Manpower conference do you want to
be successful do you want to live a life
of productivity do you want to live a
life of contribution do you want to be a
better father do you want to have your
own business are there dreams you want
everybody will say yes
but see once shows up in conversation
expectation shows up in Behavior
see I can tell what you expect by what
you do that's why the Bible says judge a
tree by the fruited Bears not the fruit
that it wants
not the fruit that it talks about not
the fruit that it claims
but by what you are doing see what you
do when you leave here when the Music
Stops when the shouting dies down your
behavior how you conduct yourself
writing your goals down deciding to
enroll in school to get a GED deciding
to sit into class with children young
enough to be your grandchildren decide
to find some product some idea some
service that you can provide so that you
can begin to create some value for
yourself so you can create wealth and
let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen it's very important that we
begin to learn how to create wealth I'm
not talking about loving money see I
believe the lack of money is the root of
all evil
steal for money
kill for money
jail for money every time the
unemployment goes up in those areas
where the unemployment is high that's
where you have the highest incidence of
crime and violence whenever the
unemployment goes up one percent in our
community ten thousand children and
women are better when money makes a
difference in your life I know
wanted to do was to be comfortable how
many of you ever want to be comfortable
raise your hands then I realize not to
be comfortable you got to be rich
[Applause]
an old friend of mine six they're gonna
say people say money won't make you
happy but everybody want to find out for
themselves
Rita Davenport say money ain't important
but it's right up there with oxygen
you got some money women will find
something cute on you
he got earlobe like Denzel honey
foreign
money makes a difference
I used to be so broke when creditors
would call a house my children would
answer the phone and say my daddy said
yeah
I was so broke at one time my life I
walked by a bank and tripped the alarm
I tell you poverty sucks you hear me
repeat after me please I'll never be
broke again
yes write that down I affirm that I'll
never be broke up here
never never
will I ever be broke again
let me tell you what money does
number one
it gives you control over your life
write that down number two it gives you
options
three
it allows you to live a life of
contribution to contribute to things
that you feel strongly about
like this ministry and the work of
project 2000 will be doing the change
the lives of young people Bishop Jake's
vision is that we can have little league
football teams and baseball teams and
basketball
judges and cardiologists and
endocrinologists so he's now
establishing an institution project 2000
to give our young people the methods the
techniques to reinvent themselves as we
go into the next millennium and this era
that Peter Drucker calls the era of the
three C's accelerated change
overwhelming complexity and tremendous
competition so here's the first step to
accumulating wealth if you expect to do
it write this down you must be willing
to do the things today others won't do
in order to have the things tomorrow
others won't have
that's why the Book of Life sent the
road to life is straight and narrow and
few there be that find it because fuel
there be that are willing to do the
things today of the us won't do
in order to have the things tomorrow of
others won't have what are the things
that others won't do number one make
discipline a major force in your life
how many of you know if you'd have been
more disciplined you'd be further along
to reach your goals right now
Socrates
in life
the road to life is straight and narrow
because few there be that are willing to
discipline themselves
here's something else that most people
won't do make it okay to okay to fail
a lot of people 85
85 prior to succeed
repeat after me please anything that's
worth doing
is worth doing badly
see anything is worth doing is worth
doing right as we have been taught if
you know how to do it but if you don't
know how to do it it's worth doing badly
until you get it right
I bet you and I wasn't there I bet you
that when Bishop TD Jakes first stood up
to preach when he gave his trial sermon
he did not have a command he did not
have the Mastery he did not have the
confidence he did not have the depth he
did not have the capacity to translate
and milk scripture like he did last
night when he first started out
now write this down
you don't have to be great to get
started but you have to get started to
be great
foreign
[Applause]
the first time I stood up to speak I
stood up and my mind sat down
I had to introduce a play at school
oh
we about
we're about to start
ran off Mr Washington Mr Brown where are
you going uh Mr Wash and I I can't think
sir I I I I don't know did you rehearse
yes sir I did well what's wrong why did
you say your lines I I don't I don't
know son I just I got up there and I
looked at him and everything left me let
me do it another day please her no go
back out there Mr Brown Mr Washington
I'll mess up please sir don't don't
don't don't send me out there now I'll
mess up Mr Brown if you run now you will
always be running anything that's worth
doing it's worth doing badly until you
get it right why are you moving right
there I gotta go to the bathroom Sir Mr
Brown go back out there yes sir
we have them to start a plea call 12
Angry Men
directed by Mr Leroy Washington
and I ran off the next day hey I found
foul
they dogged me out
they talked about me so bad the next
time another event came up Mr Washington
Mr Brown you were up I said no Mr
Washington everybody says no not him I
said they're right Mr Washington not me
he said Mr Brown you were up
yes sir
and I went out and pretty soon when
people laughed at me it didn't bother me
they would throw paper and I could catch
it without losing my concentration
[Applause]
and then one day
I came out and a hush went across the
audience because it must have been
something about me that indicated
that I had come to myself and Mr
Washington had been practicing with me
to give a presentation
and I looked at the audience and I said
I choose not to be a common man it's my
right to be uncommon if I can I seek
opportunity not security I do not wish
to be a kept citizen humbled and dull by
having the state look after me I want to
take the calculated risk to dream and to
build to fail and to succeed I refuse to
live from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the Thriller fulfillment to
the stale calm of Utopia I will never
cower before any Master nor been to any
threat it's my Heritage to stand direct
proud and unafraid to face the world
boldly and say this I have done girl
stood up say that's my boyfriend
I like me some less brown baby
but I didn't start off like that
you have something special
you have talents and abilities in you
that you don't even know so how do we
begin to create wealth let me give you
some some ideas number one write this
down knowledge
what knowledge that you have in this
economy part of what we need that people
are willing to pay you for that next is
Talent what talent
thank you
Dion's challenge playing football I
didn't have that as a talent my talent
is talking to me it's my definition of
success is doing what you love to do and
find somebody to pay you to do it
so I find people to pay me to talk I
talk I bought a game to this to this
country called beard whisk that I
invented
that's how I talk I shoot pool I signify
I make you tear up your cars break your
cue stick because I talk a lot of trash
I'll throw you off you've never been to
Boston I'll take you there so I learned
how to signify and talk trash all right
and so I make a living talking trash to
ATT I make more than one hour than
ninety percent of the American public
earned working for a whole year doing
what I love to do that I've developed my
talent you want to master your talent
find out what it is that you love to do
I love to talk scripture is another key
that says to us that what we need to do
to begin to develop ourselves Luke 12 34
where your treasure is there will your
heart be also so what do you love to do
and then explore ways in which you can
earn a living doing that cooking writing
painting working with numbers working
with people
[Music]
the other thing is not only must you
have knowledge Talent some skill
but the other thing that's important
faith
to act on whatever your dream is
see if you don't believe in yourself how
many people you know that have a lot of
talent a lot of abilities but they don't
believe in themselves raise your hands
see that faith is very important
so the faith to act on those dreams
those desires here's scripture that I
that I like very much Proverbs 16 16
chapter third verse commit thy Works
unto the Lord and thy thoughts shall be
established
commit means to carry into action
deliberately commit means to make it
happen no matter what
commitment the difference between next
time you have bacon and eggs the chicken
was involved the pig was committed he
had to give it all up that's going to
take a minute to sink in it's not all
right
see when you make a commitment I'm going
to become wealthy when you make it
important when you decide I'm going to
do it no matter what
life changes for you see most people
don't keep their commitments to their
commitments that's why they lead lives
of poverty lives of misery lives of
unhappiness
Socrates said the uncommitted life isn't
worth living
so part of what you must do whatever
commitment whatever Covenant you make
with God while you're here to go back to
be a better father to go back to make a
difference in the community to go back
to change your life to decide not to
ever to use drugs or alcohol again to
decide to bed that you're going to begin
to recreate yourself that you're going
to be reborn to a new State of
Consciousness whatever commitment that
you make keep your commitment to your
commitment no matter what if it's hard
then do it hard but keep your commitment
to your commitment
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there one of the things I have realized
and many of us have
that if you want something out of life
if you want to change yourself if you
want to acquire something if there's
some goal that you want to reach
that is really not easy as some people
will make us feel
that living your
changing your behavior behaves
overcoming negative
challenging
it's hard
[Music]
that living alone is just very difficult
and once we begin to come to grips with
the fact that living is difficult
life is very challenging I heard a song
Once by a guy named dimples call if it
ain't one thing it's another
lovers
always something you will never ever
have a problem-free moment in life
somebody said I like this and do you
either in a problem or just left one or
hit it toward what
anybody found that to be so raise your
hand if you know what I'm talking about
I only there's always something
so how do we begin to nurture that
hunger what are the characteristics of
the qualities of people that are hungry
what will it take for me to get some of
the things that I want
and being hungry for those things number
one you've got to work on yourself
it's very important that you engage in
an ongoing process to develop you spend
more time on yourself than what you've
been spending
it's very important you owe that to
yourself I was reading a book by
augmentino called the University of
success read one line gave me a chill I
didn't have to read anything else in the
book he said many of us never realize
our greatness because we become
sidetracked by secondary activity we
spread ourselves too thin don't know how
to say no and we find ourselves doing
all kinds of things and never ever have
time to do those things that we need to
do to work on ourselves and then there
goes a second there goes another second
there goes another second and we can't
stop and hold time and before you nort
you wake up one day and you're behind in
your dreams and your bills
so decide that you're going to take some
time to work on you that you deserve
that
from yourself that your life deserves
some prime time because you are creating
your own production as Michael Todd
would say you are the star of your show
you are the director you're writing the
script
and you will determine whether your life
is a smash office hit or Flop
you determine that working on yourself
talking to yourself that's so very
important
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialogue that's going on all
the time all the time even when you
don't want it to be there you can't stop
yourself right now from thinking you
can't do it it's going on
and so learning how to empower yourself
part of doing that is standing up to
yourself
you've got to stand up inside yourself
sometimes and say shut up
you've got to do this I was going to
give a presentation and this voice
inside of me saying you can't do this
you don't have everything it takes like
shut up
I ever had on my bills and you're
telling me what I can't do
to do it
your mind will go blank on you
some people you will allow to unnerve
you and you'll wonder what's wrong with
me I'm not crazy
that's why you've got to learn to make a
conscious deliberate determined effort
to stand up inside yourself
working on yourself watching that inner
dialogue it will determine the quality
of your life
I don't believe this I know this I've
had a challenge of losing weight I'm
walking through the airport this boy say
why don't you have some m m peanuts no
no
well just one
and after you eat that you might as well
have a sticker now you sucker
oh
I mean it's challenging
my mother fixed the kind of sweet potato
pie you can't eat with your shoes on
to take your shoes off so you can wiggle
your toes it sticks on my fingers it
says eat it one little bite won't hurt
that voice constantly little demons from
Colonel Sanders driving my car in there
I had to say no no no no no
our diet tomorrow
I saw a skinny man get hit by a truck
had to had a little bit more weight he
might some of you know what I'm talking
about raise your hand if you don't
that voice is awesome
so you have got to stand up
to that voice
when you're working on something you
want to achieve
you have got to stand up to that voice
you've got to sell yourself every day on
your abilities
on what you're doing on the goal that
you want to reach you've got to sell
yourself every day every day every day
according to your level of belief it
will manifest itself in what you're
doing whatever we have right now
whatever we're demonstrating in our
lives
is a result of what we believe
subconsciously that we deserve and part
of increasing that belief level is that
you have got to convince yourself every
day you've got to sell to yourself I I
do a lot of training for many
corporations and I conduct sales
seminars and I've heard all kind of guys
doing techniques and training um people
techniques of how to close sales and how
to work with and and begin to control
the the sale and how to ask for the
clothes let me share something with you
you can learn all the techniques in the
world if you don't
you don't sell
[Music]
it won't happen for you
I learned all of it
so that's why I do a training called
focus on the seller you've got to focus
on you and as you convince you
as you sell yourself every day every day
every day you will begin to see a
difference in the things that you're
doing selling yourself on your ability
to perform a job to achieve a certain
objective telling yourself every day
here I go again
and I got what it takes
this is my day and nothing out here is
going to stop me and when you go out
that life say come over here
say it again well I'll be back tomorrow
that brings me to the next thing it
takes courage to act
part of being hungry when you've been
defeated
it takes courage
to start over again
I used to do door-to-door sales
and
I was working with another friend of
mine and door-to-door sales I mean it's
punishing it's cruel and unusual
punishment
and I was a little boy knocking on the
door hello would you like to buy a nice
working television set no money now no
they slammed the door on your face and a
friend of mine that was working with me
they slammed the door on his face and I
looked back and he was going to the car
he said I can't do this
and he sat down in the car and he said
you go ahead I'll be here when you get
back now he had a mother and father to
take care of him my mother was ill I am
adopted
I was hungry
I had to go on I learned something about
myself
that when you step into your fear
somebody said it was Winston Churchill
he said that courage
is going from failure to failure without
losing enthusiasm
when you step into your
push yourself to go on
something happens for you it will enable
you to transcend yourself I went to the
next door you like to buy a nice working
tablet no bam went to the next no after
a while I no longer took it personal
and to play a game I say well I know
there's a yes out here somewhere
and I'm going to keep on till I find it
and I'm not going home until I do and I
continue to knock on doors
and then somebody eventually would say
yes and I said are you sure
and I would go on there and I would get
the sale
when you when you have something you
want to do
if you don't develop the courage
which has been given you to do and you
spend a lot of time going around trying
to convince other people trying to get
their approval what will happen is that
you will lose your nerve
and other people will convince you that
what you're doing doesn't have any value
and you'll give up on your dream it's an
interesting thing about life I've also
found that if you don't have the courage
to act
sometimes and particularly if you have
something special to do life will move
on you
I if if if it were not for life I would
still be a disc jockey I didn't just
leave voluntarily to go to the state
legislature I was fired
I was working on a job
and I came home one day I was married at
the time and I told my former wife I
said that guy bird I work for is stupid
she said if he's so stupid why does he
sign you a paycheck
now you see why I divorced her right
and her
that night I could not sleep well
here was a guy that was controlling my
life
I was going through all kind of changes
because this man controlled my paycheck
and
it was Carlisle who said truth crushed
to Earth shall rise again Winston
Churchill said the truth is
incontrovertible malice May attack it
ignorance May deride it but at the end
there it is and we know scripture that
says ye shall know the truth
and the truth shall set you free and the
truth that I had to come to grips with
that I wasn't in charge of my destiny
the truth was that I wasn't giving all
that I had
the truth was that there are some things
that I wanted to do but I didn't have
the courage to act on those things
and the truth was that bird Charles was
a blessing to me he made life so
miserable for me I had to start looking
at my life differently I started going
to work earlier I started being the last
one to leave there I started working
harder than anybody else the other guys
could not why would you work so hard Les
I said I'm not working for them I have
been cheating Bert I thought
I've been cheating myself and my family
wherever you are whatever you're doing
do it with everything that you have
develop the habit
of giving more than what you're paid for
develop the habit of setting standards
and others will be measured by someone
said do not go where the path may lead
but go where there's no path and leave a
trail
all right
easy to be negative today
it is easy to have low morale today I
was at a corporation and they're they're
going through downsizing and going to
lay off some 1500 people over the next
few weeks it's very depressing there and
those people that stay there nine times
out of ten they're just going to do just
enough to keep from getting fired
anybody can do that but if you can begin
to harness yourself
and say that where I am I'm going to do
the best I can with what I got because
that is an expression of who I am if you
get into the habit of just being
mediocre it will become a part of your
Consciousness if you get in a habit of
giving less than what you have it within
you to give it will begin to reflect
itself in your personality
it will begin to damage you
psychologically
and you don't want to be a part of that
kind of self-destructive Behavior
and so you want to set some high
standards for yourself
the next thing part of what feeds that
hunger you've got to develop a sense of
urgency
Aurelia said stop living your life like
you have a thousand years to live
in life you either hit a day and you're
gone today
if there's something that you want to do
and you can't do it all at one time do
just a little bit of it I like what
Robert Shula says he said by the yard
it's hard but inch by inch anything is
essential enough
do just a little bit of it
a friend of mine Bobby Kerr used to be a
roommate Bobby wanted to go into the
area of public relations he loved
working with the public
young lady he wanted to marry named
Clarice
Bobby was a great procrastinator
pretty soon the job where Bobby worked
they transferred him to another location
he went out to celebrate with the people
on that new job site and Bobby suffered
a massive heart attack and died
Bobby didn't drink and didn't smoke was
under 40. and he died ask you a question
how much time do you have left
how much time do you have left
when you stop thinking about that we
don't know
we don't know Bobby took all the
greatness and all of the talent and all
of his abilities to his grave with him
one of the things you could have put in
parenthesis under his name he didn't use
all his stuff
and most of most of us do that
most of us don't use the stuff that we
have brought into the universe
and we want to make a conscious
deliberate determined effort to start
living life with a sense of urgency and
using what we've got
using ourselves up
sharing what we brought into the
universe to share because if we don't
nobody else will
stop wasting valuable time
knowing that if we begin to live our
lives as if each day were our last Our
Lives will take off take on a whole new
meaning
and take on a whole new expression
valuing each moment
that we are blessed with
the next thing that begins to nurture
that hunger honor yourself as your word
don't give your word out lightly
when you throw your word out there and
you don't honor it it makes a statement
about you
if you decide
to maintain a sense of Integrity with
yourself
that if I speak it
I'm going to live it
it's who I am
and I'm going to be very cautious and
how I give my word to others and most of
all with the commitments that I make to
myself
because I want my life to reflect my
words
and honoring who I am and what I express
another challenging area in terms of
nurturing and developing that hunger in
yourself is learning the art of becoming
single-minded
learning how to concentrate
learning how to focus in
and you'll be surprised of the things
that you're able to do
when you learn how to block things out
when you learn how to keep that eyes
single you'll be surprised of the ideas
that will come to you
of the people that you'll be able to
attract
of the opportunities that you'll be able
to see you'll begin to see things that
have been staying there looking you in
the face say I can't believe this has
been here all this time
here's a habit that I do maybe it might
be of some value to you I get up in the
morning
and I start writing what great ideas can
I can think of today
that can improve me
and that will enable me to reach my goal
and I just let my mind flow sometimes I
write 50 20 ideas some days it's more
difficult than others
one idea
can change your life one idea
can turn your life around deciding that
you're going to focus to develop your
skills a guy was was um the new owner of
a team
a team a baseball team that was in the
basement of the league when he took it
over he went to the picture and he said
what is your best throat he said well I
got a good curveball and I've got a good
fast ball and he went on talking about
his different throws he said but tell me
this what is your best throw
he thought for a moment
he said I've got a good fastball
he said that's all I want you to work on
nothing else just develop your fastball
the next year they went to the World
Series most people don't know what that
fastball is
most people go through life never
discovering what their talents are most
people never develop their talents they
have skills and abilities but if you
don't nurture them if you don't develop
them they will never serve you your
gifts can take you many places if you
develop your gifts most of us don't like
to do those things that come easy to us
I've always loved to talk to people I
decided taking this advice to develop my
skills as a speaker
and my gift has developed and it
developed and has taken me many places
you have something that you brought to
the universe and that if you decide that
my life deserves my developing this what
I do well
and becoming the best at it and
mastering myself and seeing what I have
Within Me
if you decide to drop your buckets Where
You Are
and develop your gifts
I grant you you'll never ever be without
I grant you that your gifts will take
you places that will literally Amaze you
I grant you that if you begin to work to
develop your gifts
you develop a strong sense of Happiness
you'll get a larger vision of yourself
because part of beginning to get a
larger vision of yourself all of us need
some area of Our Lives where we can have
a feeling of competence
that people know when they think about
this area that's something you do
that you eat and sleep bad
and that you do that you do that
people know it and you know it and you
know that you know that you know this if
you don't know anything else you know
this can you tell I know I know what I'm
doing uh hello
you know this
so you've got to work on it
when other folk are having a good time
you've got to have this the strength of
character to concentrate to read to
digest information
if you decide
any particular area that you're
concerned about to make a conscious
deliberate determined effort to read one
book a month in that area
in five years you'll be among the top
five percent experts in the world
I read a minimum of two books a week the
average American reads only one book a
year
if you decide
that area that you love
but you are going to master that
particular area
in this era of accelerated change
overwhelming complexity and tremendous
competition
as you begin to develop and expand your
skills and your talents and your vision
of yourself
you will always be in control
of your destiny how many of you ever
decided not to do something based upon
an assumption raise your hands please
and so that's why it's important for us
to be strategic and experiential and and
being able to tell the story to distract
them from their current story distract
dispute Break Down The Limited belief
system and Inspire them to say yes to a
new opportunity in their lives and and
so as a result I didn't do what I'm
doing now
because I had such a tremendous inferior
infared inferiority complex because of
my lack of of college education I
stopped myself as an African proverb
that says there's no enemy within the
enemy outside can do us no harm and so
as you look at yourself as you look at
your goals look at your dreams it's very
important that you take time every day
and write this down to retrain your
thinking got to retrain your thinking
because how we live our lives is a
result of the story that we bought into
I had to retrain my thinking because of
what I saw studies indicating that the
decisions we make in life is directly
related
to the things that we saw the things
that we experienced the conversations
we've been exposed to between age zero
and five
and so as a result of that
my experience I had to begin to engage
in a process of retraining my mindset
and I didn't even know what I was doing
but this man Mr sandersky I'll never
forget Leslie come in here yes sir look
at my shoes you can shine them better
than this I do apologize sir I'll do a
better job and his wife said please
don't yell at him like that that's not
nice he's just a kid he's only 10 years
old he should do a better job than that
he can
I said it's okay Mrs sugerski and he
should have yelled at me he was very
rude arrogant guy but he was a kind guy
too what I loved about
his time in the morning he spent working
on his mind
and I wanted to be in the office as he
was shining his shoes listening to Earl
Nightingale all of us are self-made but
only the successful will admit it
listening to Dr Dennis Whitley people
form habits and habits prayed Futures
listening to Zig Ziglar if you give
enough people what they want they will
give you what you want listening to Jim
Rohn when the end comes for you let it
find you conquering a new Mountain not
sliding down an old one listening and
reading the words of Winston Churchill
the truth is incontrovertible malice May
attack it ignorance me to write it but
at the end there it is reading from my
favorite book be not conformed in this
world be transformed by the renewing of
your mind listening to these words
helped to create a different vision for
myself some of you are already doing it
right now I'm saying this is a time more
than ever that you want to begin to
inoculate yourself with positive words
coming to conventions showing up on
meetings being on the calls to make
yourself Unstoppable to get out of your
mind the polluting negative thoughts
that's causing most people to go through
life being stuck because they're
volunteer victims somebody said that
many people died age 25 and don't get
buried until they're 65 because they got
so much garbage in their minds you are
here because you've got a Clear Vision
of what you want and where you're going
give yourselves a round of applause
come on bring energy level up yes yes
you want more foreign
you're different
you're different than everybody else
but worry if they don't get it don't try
and convince people to do this business
a person convinced against their will is
of the same opinion still you are not
like everybody else you can walk outside
and find pigeons but if you're looking
for Eagles it's going to take you a
minute you are different it's Lonely at
the Top how many of you know it's Lonely
at the Top raise your hands it's lonely
at the top but you eat better that's
what I'm talking about
but different one great entrepreneur
said I choose not to be a common man
it's my right to be uncommon if I can I
seek opportunity not security I do not
wish to be a kept citizen humbled and
dull by having the state look after me I
want to take the calculated risk to
dream and to build to fail and to
succeed I refuse to live from hand to
mouth I prefer the challenges of life to
the guaranteed existence the thrill of
fulfillment to the still calm of Utopia
I will never call before a master nor
been to any threat it's my Heritage to
stand a wreck proud and unafraid to face
the world boldly and say this I have
done you showed up because you're
building a business that you can stand
and say I did this I did this this is my
dream give yourselves a ride of Applause
yes yes yes yes yes
foreign
there's something in you that wouldn't
allow you to stop
Dr Howard Thurman
he said there's something in each and
every one of you
that Waits
and listens to The Voice
of the genuine in yourself
it will be perhaps the only guide you
will ever have
and if you cannot hear it
all of your life your days will be spent
on the ends of strings
that somebody else pulls
and I say to you the reason you showed
up even though you couldn't afford to be
here the reason you drove hundreds of
miles flew around the world there's
something in you in your heart of hearts
it said I'm not going to let anybody
pull my strings it said I'm going to
control my own personal economy it's sad
I've got a dream I want to achieve I
want my children to have a choice of the
kind of education that they want that
said I am the captain of my ship that
said I'm going to control my destiny and
whatever it takes I'm willing to do the
work give yourselves a round of applause
1961 1961
President John F Kennedy had a decision
to make
decision was
whether or not to call a news conference
and tell the world
the United States was going to go to the
Moon
and I submit to you
that the decision to do that
was very risky
and what governed his thinking
is what govern your thinking when you
decided
I'm going to do this
see
the technology did not exist
the answer of what will it take
did not exist
no one had ever done it before
but he made a decision he looked at
Werner van Braun the most brilliant
scientist of that day
and he said Warner what will it take for
us
to go to the Moon
and he spoke five words and those five
words
I think is what governs most
entrepreneurs those five words I think
is what give people like you the courage
to pursue their dreams those five words
is what I think people who are pioneers
people who are breaking new ground
make decisions on he said what will it
take for us to go to the moon and the
response was the will to do it
as you look at yourself as you look at
your business as we looked into 2015 and
Beyond what will it take for you to
increase your business the will to do it
what will it take for you to become more
powerful in your presentation skills and
be able to increase the number of people
to quadruple your business the will to
do it what will it take for you when
others are quitting because of the
rejections when others are stopping
because they just become so discouraged
and they have predators breathing down
their neck and they have family members
and friends telling them they're full
what is it that will allow you to have
the mental resiliency to keep on keeping
on to keep your commitment to your
commitment the will to do it every time
I said and ask you a question I want you
to say the will to do it what will it
take for you to build your your business
what will it take for you to increase
your recruiting
will it take for you to bring out the
greatness in you and to make your mark
what will it take for you to become a
high achiever and to bring out the
billionaire in you
this one's hand on your right and left
and say I've got the will
Mr Washington
this man who taught me he said Mr Brown
you want to make it in life he said
number one
develop your mind you don't get in life
what you want you get in life what you
are
number two
develop your communication skills once
you open your mouth you tell the world
who you are
three
practice the principle of oqp
only quality people let us say together
only quality people
as you think about your goals and dreams
this is not for everybody
you want to build an organization with
only
not people who need more but people who
want more
you want to surround yourself
with people that are hungry
people that are hungry are willing to do
the things a day others won't do in
order to have the things tomorrow others
won't have people that are hungry do
what they know not what they feel see I
didn't do this for years because I knew
it would be hard
and Mr Washington said something to me
Mike Williams my mentor you want to go
online and find his book The Road to
your best stuff
he said something that grabbed me and I
want you to put this someplace where you
can see it see you build this business
through persistence you got to affirm I
will persist until I succeed you build
it through patience it takes time to
grow orchids it's faster to grow roses
but orchids that takes time
you have to have persistence you have to
have patience and perseverance
it takes courage to come back again and
again and again because in order to
build the business it's hard work it's
h-a-r-d
and h-e-a-r-t
[Music]
are you with me there
write this down
if you do what is easy
your life will be hard
but if you do what is hard
your life will be easy
if you do what is easy
point out all this to some pyramid
scheme oh I've been talking to people
and nobody's interested I talk to people
and they said no oh I've done that
before
come up with excuses if you do what is
easy always looking for a way to give
yourself a pass to let yourself off the
hook to do what everybody else is doing
a job the Journey of the broke
if you do what is easy
your life will be hard
people working on jobs that they hate
that they hate the
heart attack rate on Monday morning
between six o'clock and ten o'clock
increases by 35
people going to jobs that they hate
if you do what is easy your life will be
hard working two and three jobs so one
paycheck and no job security
but there's something in you
that says you know I'm making some good
money but you know what
I can't do this
I can't do this anymore a friend of mine
she's here I'm so honored to be in her
presence Kim wheat she went to do a
presentation drove from
Los Angeles to San Francisco
and 20 people in Rome and they said yes
she's an electrifying speaker great
presenter yes
and when she left the dream Busters took
the floor
and when the dream buses finish with
those people who had goals and dreams of
a new life they sabotaged him
and they called her before she can get
home and say no
we're not going to do it
and at that moment she could have quit
write this down your private voice
every entrepreneur you have two things
going for you have an energy signature
and some of you will be working with and
you have a private voice
eight to nine decisions out of ten that
you make a governed by that private
voice
when they called and said no her private
voice said
you're wasting your time you don't need
to do this your husband is a doctor you
don't need to do this your mother you
need to spend more time with your child
get this crazy idea out of your mind but
rather than do that she started talking
to herself rather than do that she
started listening to motivational
messages that will build herself up from
the inside and as a result a verse
saying yes I can do this as a result of
ignoring the dream Busters now she's one
of the top 10 producers in the world in
multi-level marketing give her a round
of applause can we stand up give Round
of Applause yes
yes
in the world
and that's why you are here
there's a voice in you
that is said
I can do this I know others have failed
I can do this I know others have said
that that I can't do it
I've had said birth backs in life how
many of you had some failures raise your
hands please
have you had some nose in your life
raise your hands please Shake someone
down on your right and left and say make
know your vitamin
ladies and gentlemen
if you want to make it in life you got
to make know your vitamin
you've got to know every no brings you a
step closer to a yes
anybody can stop because someone said no
but there's something in you
in Your Heart of heart to say I'm not a
quitter
there's something in you that says I've
got the will to do it there's something
in you that says I'm going to find a way
Mr Brown what do you want to do with
your life young man sir I'd like to
become a disc jockey why Sarah because I
want to buy my mother a home he said
great listen to Paul Harvey here are my
car keys going to call 12 noon he comes
on every day why because if you want to
be successful study the people that are
doing what you want to do he's the best
in the world when it comes to
communication I suggest to you as you
look at what you want to achieve look at
the top Achievers understand and know
they are only an example they are not an
exception they're an example of what you
can do because success leaves Clues
follow the system watch the leaders and
study them
I did that and he said Mr Brown detoxify
your life let all the negative people in
your life go can I change them no it's a
full-time job changing yourself he's
right
he's right you can't change people
it's hard changing yourself
and there's some people so negative they
can walk into a dark room and begin to
develop
thank you
he said practice oqp only quality people
he said I want you to see yourself as a
disc jockey you want to be a disc jockey
visualize yourself being on radio you
want to be a top performer visualize
yourself building the business visualize
yourself coming across the stage
accepting an award for your recognition
of your hard work
see it in your mind's eye he said I'll
give you all your eyes can see
and I had to see myself on stage as I'm
presenting right now I've been here many
times before I showed up in my mind all
your goals are achieved Twice first in
the mind then and without and then
finally he said Mr Brown I said yes sir
you want to be a disc jockey yes sir he
said you got to be hungry I said why you
keep saying that he said people that are
hungry are Relentless people that are
hungry Unstoppable people that are
hungry no excuse is acceptable I said
sir
I'm hungry to take care of my mother
all my life people have always compared
me to my brother because I'm not smart
like him it takes me longer to get
things than most people I have to hear
it again and again but once I got it sir
I got it you you're the only person that
never called me stupid or dumb
you never call me DT the dumb twin
you you look at me like um
why come somebody
I've never had a father and I
I watch you
and I want to be able to talk like you I
I get choked up sometimes because I
can't get my thoughts out sir
but I want to do what you do and
I want to make my mom a proud
he said you can do it Mr Brown
I've given you all you can
get from me now it's on you if you want
to be a disc jockey go out
into the marketplace I went to apply for
a job on Miami Beach Milton Butterball
Smith was a program director hello Mr
Butterball how are you sir my name is
Les Brown so I like to be a disc jockey
your man you're having journalism in
your background no sir I don't have
experience in broadcasting no sir but
let me let me addition for you so let me
show you how good I am all I want sir is
a shot just let me let me audition he
said no how many have been rejected
racial aspects
I was devastated with rejection I said
Mr Washington they said no he said don't
take it personally most people are still
yes
I said yes
[Music]
I came back the next step
come on how are you sir my name is
[Music]
yes
[Music]
about your goals and dreams
and became the urban boy for the
discharges
[Music]
I expect
to live my dream
I began to serve them my favorite book
says
and so pretty soon
building a relationship people build
relation people may know life and Trust
proven themselves and as they look here
young boy
who cleaned my car today I did Sir
how much is all you nothing sir you
cleaned it inside and out you watched it
yes I don't owe you anything no sir
I just wanted to help out write this
down give before you ask I was giving
service
I was giving Service First
he said whoa
yeah Donna Ross and The Supremes are
coming to town The Four Tops and The
Temptations here are my car keys pick
them up and take them to the Fountain
Blue Hotel on Miami Beach I said be my
pleasure to serve you sir I would drive
these entertainers all over Miami Beach
and the disc jockeys big long Cadillacs
I didn't have any driver's license but
I'll drive it like a handsome
then one day
it was a Saturday afternoon a disc
jockey by the name of rock and Roger was
drinking while he was on the air he
began to slur his words he got so drunk
he was about to fall off the chair it
was a Saturday afternoon and I was the
only one there
looking at him through the control room
window
walking back and forth
Young
ready
all right
now
[Music]
[Music]
front porch
foreign
I waited for about 20 minutes and I
called him back and said Mr Klein I
can't find nobody
controls I said yes sir he
said don't you say nothing here
I said yes sir
I couldn't wait to get a rock out of the
way I put on a fast record I say look
how this is me lb triple P Les Brown
your Plata plan Papa there were nothing
before me and there will be none after
me therefore that makes me the one and
only youngest England love Domingo
certified Bonafide doably qualified to
bring you satisfaction and a whole lot
of action look out they
've
read
I was hungry
I was hungry
Shake someone's hand and say you got to
be hungry Shake someone's head and say
you got to be hungry
you got to be hungry
so I'd like to leave this with you
I don't know what you want to do
but I believe that Zig was right you
give enough people what they want they
will give you what you are
I believe Jim Rome was right when the
end comes to you let it find you conquer
in the new Mountain
not sliding down an 0-1 I believe Earl
Nightingale was right all of us are
self-made but only the successful will
admit it I believe that Dr pill was
right always strive to get on top in
life because the bottom is overcrowded I
believe Mike Williams is right if you do
what is easy your life will be hard but
if you do what is hard your life will be
easy
so I dedicate this to you to the dreamer
in you something my mother used to love
to hear me say Leslie yes ma'am mama
say that thing for me boy that makes me
feel good I dedicate this to you
because it's one thing to be in the
business but there's something else in
the business is in you
you are here because it's in you
it's in your heart and it says simply
this if you want to think bad enough to
go out and fight for it to work day and
night for it to give up your time your
peace and your sleep for it if all that
you dream and scheme is about it and
life seems useless and worthless without
it and if you gladly sweat for it and
fret for it and plan for it and lose all
your Terror of the opposition for it and
if you simply go after that thing that
you want with all of your capacity
strengthen sagacity faith hope and
confidence and Stern per tenacity if
neither cold poverty famish adult
sickness or pain or body and brain can
keep you away from the thing that you
want if dog had had Grim you besieged
and beset it with the help of God you'll
get it Dr Howard Thurman one of the
mentors of Dr Martin Luther King Jr and
Albert Schweitzer and Mahatma Gandhi it
was a very brilliant writer he wrote
some things that really grabbed me he he
wrote deep is the hunger
the voice of the genuine
the sinnering moment during the time
after receiving 238 radiation seed
implants I was reflecting on his words
and and these words kept me up that
night he said the ideal situation for a
man or woman to die
is to have family members praying with
them as they cross over he said but
imagine if you will being on your death
bed and standing around your bed the
ghost of the dreams the ideas the
abilities the talents given to you by
life and that you for whatever reason
you never went after that dream
you never acted on those ideas you never
use those talents you never use those
gifts and there they are standing around
your bed looking at you with large Angry
Eyes saying we came to you
and only you could have given us life
and now we must die with you forever
[Music]
and the question is
if you die today
what dreams
what ideas
what talents what books what music what
leadership what voice will die with you
miles Monroe great origin speaker said
the wealthiest place in the planet it's
not in the Far East where there's oil in
the ground it's not a South Africa where
the diamond mines he said the wealthiest
place on the planet it's the cemetery
because there you'll find greatness that
we've never seen there you'll find
talent and genius and potential never
actualize
perhaps that's why Henry David Thoreau
wrote the words oh God to reach the
point of death only to realize that
you've never lived maybe that's why some
unknown writer wrote the words what if
you live your whole life only to
discover
that it was wrong
wrong that it was wrong
that you were chosen to do
something else
and you didn't do it
[Music]
repeat after me please live full
die empty
I want you to take some notes into
things and I want you to think about
your goals and dreams in the three
categories that I mentioned personal
professional
and your social contribution
how many of you serious about your goals
and dreams raise your hands please
thank you very much how many of you
don't want to take your dreams to your
grave with you raise your hands please
very good shakes the one's hand on your
right and left look him in the eyes and
say get out of your head and step into
your greatness do that right now please
say get out of your head and step into
your greatness
I want you to write this down let us say
together as you think about your goals
and dreams let us stay together it's
possible together please
yes write that down
see ladies and gentlemen as an
entrepreneur
I've been an entrepreneur for 20 years
it's my 21st year
I could have been speaking and training
for 34 years
but for 14 years I was living in my head
for 14 years I stopped myself for 14
years I used to go see Zig Ziglar that I
considered the number one motivational
speaker on the planet Zig ziglan Tony
Robbins they're the best on the planet
Bob Proctor they are the best on the
planet Jack Canfield Mark Victor Hansen
T.I Beckett I would go and see them and
then I would leave in my conversation
with myself was my heart would say I can
do that and then my mind would ask how
how would you do that Les Brown see when
I was in the fifth grade I was
identified as EMR labeled educatable
mentally [ __ ] put back from the
fifth grade to the fourth grade I failed
again when I was in the eighth grade I
have no College training and a man
changed my life and I'll never forget
his name Mr Leroy Washington he's in his
80s now and and he's blind from glaucoma
but he he gave me a different vision of
myself I was in his class waiting on
another student he came in and said
young man go to board and work this
problem out for me I said oh sir I can't
do that I said why not I said I'm I'm
not one of your students said look at me
yes sir go to the board and work the
problem on anyhow I said sir I I can't
do that he said why because it's there
because I'm educable mentally [ __ ]
sir I'm in special education and the
students started laughing they said
that's Leslie that's not Wesley he's DT
Wesley it's the smart twin he said what
does DT stand for I said I'm I'm the
dumb twin sir and as the students
laughed at me he came from behind his
desk he looked at me and he said don't
you ever say that again someone's
opinion of you does not have to become
your reality
foreign
I was humiliated but on the other hand I
was liberated because he looked at me
with the eyes of girder who said look at
a man the way that he is he only becomes
worse but look at him as if he were what
he could be then he becomes what he
should be
and so we developed a relationship and
one of the things that I can just tell
you as you think about your goals and
dreams all of us can say in a spirit of
Integrity that it's possible that if
anybody at any point in time lived their
dream that it's possible that I could
live mine and what I did was I made a
mistake I looked at my goals and dreams
and my mind said how will you do that I
went from my heart to my mind and I
stayed up there for 14 years 14 years I
can't bring those 14 years back those
years are gone
and I've made a mission in my life to
help people to stop putting it off and
procrastinating how many ever thought
about something you wanted to do and you
procrastinated you talked yourself out
of it raise your hand please there's a
proverb that says if there's no enemy
within the enemy outside can do us no
harm
and so as you look at your goals and
dreams every day we must convince
ourselves we must sell ourselves on that
it's possible every seminar every
Workshop every book that I've ever read
every speaker that I've ever heard it
interrupted what I was believing about
myself everything that you do everything
matters
as you go through each day I know now as
I look back at age 63 looking at my life
everything matters T Hoff is right how
you do anything is how you do everything
and I realize that the choices I was
making was based upon how I saw myself
let us say together it's necessary
write that down it's necessary as you
look at your goals and your dreams it's
necessary that you have a strategy and a
game plan to change the story that you
believe about yourself
and that's an ongoing process I
discovered and many people have that
what we do what we accomplish what we
produce is a result of the story We
believe about ourselves my favorite book
says Biggie and I conform to this word
be transformed by the renewing of your
mind and so as I began to work on myself
I realize that I'm getting out of one
story and stepping into another story as
I become aware of some things there's
still some things I'm not aware of so I
still I'm still growing I'm still
developing I'm like the lady who said
Lord I ain't want to wanna be what I'm
going to be but thank God I showed what
I was
but I realize that that you have to work
on yourself on a regular basis and write
this down for mental mindset
for mental mindset and stamina
because things are going to happen to
you I don't believe I believe that the
reason that most people go to their
graves where their talents and abilities
and skills in them is because of the
fact number one many are like me they
didn't know that they didn't know and
and thought they knew I thought I knew
myself and I really didn't know myself
as well as I thought I've discovered
that sometimes people can take you to a
place within yourself that you can't go
by yourself
the other reason is I was afraid
I never worked for a major corporation I
wanted to speak for corporations
I was afraid I would I would be exposed
because I don't have a college education
I felt inferior because of the fact that
I don't have a college education
I allowed that level of fear of failure
to stop me and because I never had any
experience in it I assume that I could
not do it I was paralyzing Myself by
believing and assuming the limited part
of myself as opposed to believing that I
had something special you have something
special there's something you want to do
because you don't know how to do it
doesn't mean that you can't learn I like
something that I heard you don't have to
be great to get started but you have to
get started to be great
repeat after me please leave
and grow your wings on the way down
see the people that will live their
dreams the two percent that will do that
these are and write this down become a
risk taker they're Risk Takers they
don't mind failing they don't mind
making mistakes they're willing to take
life on take life in the column this God
said if you're not willing to risk you
cannot grow and if you cannot grow you
cannot become your best and if you
cannot become your best you can't be
happy and if you can't be happy then
what else is there I like what Helen
Keller said she said life is short and
unpredictable eat the dessert first I
don't care how good you are I don't care
how talented you are I don't care how
much you work on yourself there are some
times when things aren't going to go
right
they just are not going to go right
there are times when anything that can
happen will happen Murphy's Law will be
knocking at your door
why I don't know why that's called life
and you have to deal with it
sometimes your life will be in a slump
just like sports
some of the best Shooters can't hit
baskets different times in games they
get in a slump do they sit on the
sideline and say you know I just didn't
hit a basket today no they continue to
execute I suggest to you that if you
were facing a challenge don't stop
stay busy work your plan continue to do
those things that you know that work for
you after you have evaluated yourself
from the situation continue to move stay
busy stay busy stay busy repeat after me
help somebody
and help yourself because what you give
because is what you get
find somebody that you can help so you
can forget about you for a moment see
sometimes the best thing to do is to be
sometimes you have to just back up and
go within yourself a bow and arrow you
you can't take a boat and just push it
out an hour you just can't push the
arrow out you have to pull it back
and then release it
sometimes you have to back up and go
within and pray and meditate and
recharge your batteries go away clear
your head and then come back and look at
it from a different vantage point
don't operate while you're under the
spell or the effect of what's going on
next thing is that you've got to
activate the Thinker in you
don't allow your emotions to control you
we are emotional but you want to begin
to discipline your emotion
if you don't discipline and contain your
emotions they will use you
your mind goes on automatic just like a
god you know
I loved reading the book called as a man
thinking by James Allen he uses the
analogy of the mind being like a garden
you know weeds don't have to have any
encouragement to grow
sunshine
sidewalk am I right
yeah
but if you want to grow orchids or roses
or any kind of exotic flowers there are
special processes and procedures you
must go through
well by the same token you don't have to
force yourself or motivate yourself to
think negatively
to be depressed to hate somebody to want
revenge you want to get back at somebody
to beat yourself up over the head to
feel loaded with guilt you don't have to
make any effort to do that your mind is
on automatic it will do that by itself
but if you want to begin to move into
your own personal greatness if you want
to begin to really enjoy a happy
successful healthy life you've got to be
willing to go against the tide you've
got to be willing to harness your will
and say in spite of this
I'm in control here
I'm not going to let this get me down
I'm not going to let this destroy me
I'm coming back
and I'll be stronger and better because
of it you have got to make a declaration
[Music]
that this is what you stand for you're
standing up for your dreams you're
standing up for peace of mind you're
standing up for health
you want it
and you're going to go all out to have
it
it's not going to be easy when you want
to change it's not easy if it were in
fact easy everybody would do it but if
you're serious you'll go all out
to yes
I'm going to turn this situation around
I'm not going to sit back and and moan
and cry over what happened and what went
wrong and who did what
I'm going to do something about this
situation
the next thing that is important
is that it's things to get better for
you because they are
they are you're not what is exp whatever
experience you're having right now it
has not come to stay
it has come to pass
not to stay just to pass it's just going
through
the biggest challenge is is to know
what's happening this is a part of this
thing we call life this too shall pass
and maintaining perspective putting it
in perspective
I was doing a training at a college
and
the two-day training during orientation
and in the training that I provide I'm a
motivational speaker but I conduct
processes and personal Dynamics
where people begin to go through changes
that stimulate the right and left
hemisphere of the brain enable them to
see themselves differently I conducted
this particular simulation with these
young kids 17 and 18 years of age so
that they would begin to see how they
make decisions how they would survive in
this particular simulation process we
gave them
we had them to do it individually and
then collectively
over 30 percent of them
wrote down as their first option in
order to survive they would commit
suicide
first thing they wrote down
suicide among young people has increased
300 over 5 000 will successfully take
their lives this year why why did they
do that they fasted I was so shocked I
said what do you mean well at least we
would not suffer
and then they had the nerve to write
down all of the other things they were
going to do after they committed suicide
foreign
no when you when you come up with a
permanent solution for a temporary
problem that's it game's over
that's it you're not going to do
anything anybody wrote suicide at the
top you can put your pencil down
see a lot of us because of our limited
vision of ourselves a lot of us who
begin to focus on problems and enable
them to overwhelm us we begin to think
that we have no options we begin to
believe that there's no way out repeat
after me there's always a way
where there's a will
there's a way Shake somebody's hand on
your right left and say I'm unstoppable
you've got to make those kind of
declarations to yourself
I'm unstoppable
this will not get me down
and if I get knocked down
I'm gonna be like um Leo Pascal you said
you're going to have some low moments in
life but when you do you will have high
lows
learn your work on yourself what are
some of those things that you can do
during this period of time go for walks
do some things for you just go for a
stroll so you can engage in some
reflective thinking on life on yourself
looking and enjoying the universe
smelling the Roses along the way
listen to upbeat music music that
inspire you I have only but goodies I
have strategies that I engage in to
recharge my batteries I'm preparing for
that because I know things are going to
happen that I cannot anticipate very
good friend of mine died the other day I
had a program for myself I have books
that I read that inspire me tapes that I
listen to that fire me up because you're
going to have sometimes low moments when
you won't want to get out of bed
you just want to stay there
at times you won't want to come out the
house the times you'll be feeling bad
and don't know why what's wrong I don't
know
just leave me alone
why did that happen I don't know it's
called life
the other thing is take full
responsibility for your life
except Where You Are and the
responsibility that you're going to take
yourself where you want to go someone
said we have two primary choices in life
we can either accept conditions as they
exist or we can take the responsibility
to change them see a lot of people want
to exempt themselves from taking
responsibility all they want to do is
talk about the problem every time you
see them they'll tell you their story
over and over and over and over again
no no you want to take responsibility
for your life I got me here I can get me
out of this
and I'm getting out
I'm not going to be a volunteer victim
George Bernard Shaw said there are two
kinds of people in life
you know he said those that make things
happen those that watch things happen
and those that don't know what happened
and he said the people that get along in
this life look around for the
circumstances that they want and if they
can't find them they make them they
create
like you've got to decide that the
behavior pattern that you have adopted
doesn't work for you you've got to
change your strategies and changing your
strategy means Reinventing Your Life
recreating you and you have the power to
do that
decide that you're going to change that
you're not going to be a wimp
you can decide that you're going to
stand up to life
you can decide that I'm going to live
each day as if it were my last
you can you have the power to make that
decision
you can decide I'm going to work on
myself and develop myself I'm going to
empower me
and all of these things that are
happening to me right now they're just
temporary inconveniences they're not
stronger than I am
I'm in charge here yeah see one of the
things about life you're going to get
hurt you're going to make some mistakes
you're going to feel your way to success
but you've got to be willing to
experiment you got to be willing to push
yourself you've got to be willing to
challenge yourself by putting yourself
in a Perpetual state of discomfort and
so but things happen in life when you
have goals and dreams things happen
had no idea Midway of my third term my
mother became ill she was diagnosed with
breast cancer my brothers and sisters
called me and said they're going to put
her in a nursing home and I said no they
said we thought you would say that we've
interviewed the best nursing homes in
Dade County I said I said no so I had a
problem how can one woman raise seven
children who couldn't take care of
themselves but seven grown people
couldn't take care of one woman I had a
problem with that
and I've said no
some resigned from the Ohio legislature
and I came back to Miami to take care of
Mama
and took care of until 89.
and there are things as you have your
goals things are going to happen to you
that you can't anticipate some of you in
the eye of the storm now
things are going to happen and don't say
why does this have to happen to me why
not you who would you suggest
you want to give us some names and email
addresses
that's really what I said the second
time I got cancer
they had told me the cancer metastasized
the seven areas of my body I started
laughing he said why are you laughing
are you in denial I said no I feel like
Mother Teresa he said what do you mean
she said Lord I know you know how much I
can bear I just wish I you didn't have
so much confidence in me
there's times in your life when things
going to happen that you've got to begin
to put your dream on hold
and you might have to reinvent yourself
how many have already gone through that
raise your hands please it's called life
and don't tell everybody about it eighty
percent don't care and 20 Glad Is You
you have to suck it up and handle it
that's what it called being in business
being an entrepreneur being a risk taker
walking by faith and not by sight stuff
happens to you it's hard changing your
life
it was hard when just over three years
ago in the Penobscot building in Detroit
Michigan
where I was operating my business
and I fell on some hard times
and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said excuse me Mr Brown Can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope
and he said would you mind reading it
here and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that said
this is an office tower
it's not a hotel
please
do not sleep in your office
and I said excuse me sir I said I just
worked long hours
and creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be this way always
and I just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate like I'm doing I'm
not trying to make this my home
and it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh there's a
guy talking about becoming successful
and look at him he's bathing in the
bathroom upstairs on the 21st floor he
sleeps on the floor him and two other
dreamers up there look at them
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people
and I was facing financial difficulties
in my own life
I was behind on my bills and my dreams
and I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I could do it
there were times that I doubted myself I
said God why why is this happening to me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a rock from anybody
why did this have to happen to me
it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream
no one could have convinced me by
holding on
by continuing to push forward
by continuing to run toward my dream
that one day
I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
on a floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot being here with you today in
this Dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot no College
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ] but I kept running toward my
dream
don't stop
don't stop
foreign
don't stop running towards your dream
it's very important
as you hold on to that dream
[Applause]
they're moments when you're going to
doubt yourself
their rough times are going to come but
they have not come to stay they have
come to pass
it's very important for you to know that
don't say I'm having a bad day Sam
having a character building day
[Applause]
it's very important for you to believe
that you are the one
to make this happen I remember
this High School teacher Mr Leroy
Washington
at the end of school one June it was
just a few days before we were supposed
to leave
and I just got my report card
and it indicated that I'd fail history
and I'd fail English
and I would have to go to summer school
and I was feeling Within Myself
that I was a failure that I I'm sure
that most people and getting paperwork
and and I was feeling down on myself and
and very negative
and Mr Washington was giving a speech to
the graduating seniors and I was in 11th
grade
and even though I wasn't supposed to be
in there
I went in there because the speech he
was giving that speech was for me
and as he talked my heart began to beat
fast
tears began to run by my eyes and I was
in the back just listening to him
because he said and he was a very
dramatic man
I still talk to him to this day
he said as graduating seniors of Booker
T Washington High School
I want you to know that you're blessed
and highly favored
and that as you go toward the future
begin to know that you have greatness
within you
and if just one of you here
begin to Envision yourselves as being
blessed and highly favored to reach your
goals if just one of you
capture the essence of what that means
that you have greatness within you and
responsibility to manifest that
greatness
that you can make your parents proud you
can make your school proud you can touch
millions of people's lives and the world
will never be the same again because you
came this way and the students gave him
a rousing standing ovation and as he
left the auditorium I ran down the steps
and I caught him in the parking lot I
said Mr Washington
he said yes I said do you remember me
sir
he said no I said um my name is Leslie
Brown my mother she works in the
cafeteria here I'm one of the twins
Leslie and Wesley I said Miss Washington
but you know you know I got these Big
Dreams you know I like talking to people
I love people I said I want to work with
people and I got this dream of buying my
mom a home
could could I do that Mr Washington
he said it's possible Mr Brown
and as he walked away I call him again I
said Mr Washington
he said what do you want now
I said uh
I'm the one sir
I said
I'm the one you you remember me sir
I miss maybe Brown's boy
I'm the one
I'm the one
thank you
[Applause]
and you must feel that
that that's why you're here
because you are the one
and I remember when PBS first played one
of my specials called you deserve one
Sunday afternoon in Miami Florida
I had some friends call him to tell him
to tune in
and he watched the program he called me
in Detroit and I answered the phone and
I said hello he said may I speak to Les
Brown please I said who's calling
he said you know who this is
I said Oh Mr Washington it's you
he said you were the one weren't you
I said yes sir he said and you were so
crazy I said I know but I'm rich now
laughs
ladies and gentlemen
it's not going to be easy
it was hard laying on the floor of the
Penobscot building looking out of the
window daydreaming saying less can you
do this can you make this happen
I used to listen to tapes day in and day
out
about see you at the top my my great
friend Zig and and Dennis Whitley
different other motivational speakers
and Dr Norman Vincent field and Dex is
saying don't let nobody steal your dream
I used to ask myself can I do this
and something said Within Me
you're the one
you're the one
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen
while you're here
and before you go back home to your
respective cities and communities
write down at least five reasons
on why you deserve your dream
and why you won't give up
what's going to make you Unstoppable why
you must be unreasonable because logical
practical thinking says you can't do it
today but if you want to produce
unreasonable results in your life like
living your dreaming taking charge of
your destiny you've got to be an
unreasonable person you've got to be an
uncommon person
so write down the reasons of why you're
here
my first major goal
was to buy my mother a home
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen what what will reasons do less
Nietzsche said if you know the rifle
doing you can endure almost anyhow what
do you mean by that if you know why
you're doing something when the hard
times come and they're going to come
when the disappointments and rejections
come and they're going to come by the
truckloads your reasons will be your rod
and staff to comfort you to pick you up
once again I got a saying on one of my
tapes if life knocks you down try and
land on your back because if you can
look up you can get up let your reasons
get you back up
[Music]
I remember when I I bought the home for
my mother and she came
out of the car when I opened the door I
said Mom I think I know these people in
this house that's my first major goal
and then I couldn't conceal it anymore I
said Mom I got this for you
and as she went from room to room
looking at the house and saying thank
you Jesus
thank you Lord no one ever
could have convinced me that this could
have happened to me
and she looked at me she said Leslie
and you cost me so much problems as a
boy you were always into stuff
she said no one could have convinced me
that day when I walked in that house
and this lady was holding you and your
brother
and she said ma'am I want you to promise
me two things
and she'd say what is it she says one
promised me
that you won't separate them she said I
want them raised together I want them to
know each other I got pregnant while my
husband was away in the war and I can't
keep him
promise me
that you won't separate them she said I
promise I won't I've never had children
I promise I won't separate him and she
said promise me that you'll never tell
them about who I am because if my
husband ever found out he would kill me
she said I promise
and she said that she gave them to us
and and she kind of cried and she and
she was walking out the door and she
looked at my adopted mother she said
remember
don't you separate him
she said I swear to God I won't
I won't separate am I keep them together
and she said if I held you all in my
arms I never had any children of my own
I didn't know how I was going to do it
but I knew with the help of God
I will do it
and ladies and gentlemen
my mother had a dream of having children
and raising us she didn't know how she's
going to do it you're going to be just
like that and some of you are already
there well you don't know how
you're going to make this happen but you
just feel within yourself some way
somehow with the help of God I'm going
to make it happen repeat after me please
no matter how bad it is
or how bad it gets
[Applause]
I'm going to make it
I'm going to make it
Shake somebody's hand on your right and
left and say you got the right stuff
so yes
it's possible for you to live your dream
it's necessary that you associate with
winners that you worked your system that
you are Relentless that you never give
up
it's you you've got to take personal
responsibility you've got to make it
your personal business to make it happen
and you've got to resolve within
yourself that I can do this that it's
hard but you've got to say I'm the one
I'm the one to make this happen I'm the
one to become successful in this
business as you work to help other
people to become successful that feeds
your success
but you know it's going to be hard but
find out what will make it worth it for
you
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one interview with Les Brown
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there whatever Vision
that you hold for yourself see it
accomplish and understand this
it can be done
and the glue is service
belief